Blue Moon, Blue Moon, Blue Moon, Chaos Radio. Jeden letzten Mittwoch im Monat gibt es hier einen ganz speziellen Blue Moon, nämlich das Chaos Radio mit dem Chaos Computer Club und mit Johnny. Es gibt jeden Monat neue Themen und manchmal auch Themen, die sich wiederholen. So zum Beispiel heute, das heißt wiederholen tut sich nur das Thema. Der Inhalt ist natürlich ein neuer Thema heute im Chaos Radio. Hacking The Internet Teil 2. Die regelmäßigen Hörern und Hörerinnen dieser Sendung wird was aufgefallen sein, dass nämlich...
Was ist denn da?
Wir machen gerade Musik hier.
Dass nämlich am Anfang Kraftlaken zählt haben.
Ganz frustriert. Elend.
Das ist nicht schön.
Ich würde dir nicht mehr zählen, dass es hier keine Audio-Kabel gibt.
Du meinst ja, bei dir ist wieder Hacking's Nase.
Ich nehme alles auf dich.
Damit haben wir schon mal einen Schuldigen für diese Sendung.
Dafür habe ich wieder ein wunderbar nutzloses Stück Papier hier erzeugt, was sich keiner durchsieht.
Ich habe nur so ein großes.
Das habe ich überflogen.
Und hier ist noch ein In-House.
Nein, mein, da habe ich es geguckt. Ein In-House.
Ein In-House. Welchen Teil hast du dafür versprungen?
Du musst da ins Mikro reden.
Welchen Teil hast du denn versprungen? Genau so.
Ähm, gar keinen.
Er hat es nicht übersprungen. Er hat es überflogen. Immerhin kann ich mich ruhigen, dir Fliegen beigebracht zu haben.
Ich werde mit manchen Begriffen mich da nicht so...
Okay, ich werde auch meine Witze einstellen.
Deswegen bin ich auch wahrscheinlich kein guter Programmierer. Ich gebe es mir mal mit den Worten nicht so richtig ernst. Ah, Robcoma oder Simikola, das ist doch wurscht. Hacking The Internet Teil 2, kann sich jemand noch an Teil 1 erinnern? Wie lange ist denn das her?
Schon einige, kann man sagen. Es ist schon ein bisschen her, aber wir haben festgestellt, dass es nach wie vor aktuell ist. Eigentlich wird es sogar permanent aktueller. In letzter Zeit ist einfach dermaßen viel passiert, dass man mal wieder was Smaller aufmachen muss.
Es ist eigentlich erstaunlich, dass Widerwartendes Internet doch nicht verschwunden ist.
Nachdem wir mehrfach ernannt haben, dass das Internet scheiße ist, hat es einen Steck gegeben.
Es hat uns nicht geglaubt.
Auf uns hört ja eigentlich auch keiner.
Chaos Computer Club mäßiges Thema, also richtig heute. Hacking The Internet. Es gibt vier Leute heute im Studio. Vielleicht mal kurz durchsagen, wer wieder da ist. Tim ist ja regelmäßig dabei, ne?
Ja, ja. Ich bin hier so ausrüstungstandard. Ich bin betar.
Felix, was ist das letzte Mal hier dabei?
Schon eine Weile her. Ich hab in der Zwischenzeit kurz in München gewohnt und deswegen schon länger hier.
Da hat man ihn, glaub ich, telefonisch dabei gehabt. Damit er endlich in München aufreiztrennen konnte.
Und wie ist das so in Bayern?
Auch gar nicht so schlimm, wie ich gedacht hatte, ehrlich gesagt. Ich darf jetzt hier eh nicht meckern, weil es ja bei MPEG doch in Bayern auch ankommt. Nachher lasst du mich an der Grenze nicht mehr reiten.
Ja, wir grüßen natürlich auch ganz herzlich die Spezialgehörer in Bayern heute. Auf Kanal 17 können Sie diese Sendung in der Mundart verfolgen.
Das ist vielleicht eine Hölle.
Ich bin ein Dumpfhansel, ich bin ein Dumpfhansel. Ich bin ein Dumpfhansel, ich bin ein Dumpfhansel. So, bevor wir euch eine Einführung in die Thematik geben, bzw. euch erzählen, worum es in den nächsten drei Stunden gehen wird, genauer beim Thema Hacking The Internet oder hackend das Internet zu Deutsch, die verschiedenen Kommunikationswege mit uns. Es wird natürlich nachher die Möglichkeit geben, für euch hier anzurufen, also mit uns zu telefonieren. Ihr könnt euch aber auch mit anderen Hörern und Hörerinnen unterhalten. Da gibt es zwei verschiedene Chatwege, außer natürlich dem, den es sowieso gibt, im IRC selber Kanäle eröffnen, weil sie nicht Chaosradio oder so gibt es eigentlich immer, ne?
Keine Ahnung, ja, ja, ja, wird immer erzielt, dass das auch...
Sagen alle! Dann gibt es für die, die vielleicht mit dem IRC nicht so umgehen können oder mit solchen Geschichten, die können das ganz normal unter ihrem Browser tun. Da braucht ihr nur Frames-fähig sein. Und dann geht man zu www.fritz.de slash speakers. Da kann man sich mit Menschen unterhalten, im Studio-Chat. Da gibt es einen Telnet-Chat, wenn man keine Handweite hat.
Ja, und das ist das dann.
Klassisch und toll.
Hat den Vorteil, dass wir das in der Sendung auch sehen können.
Genau, we are watching you. Ihr könnt auch dumme Fragen fragen, aber geht nicht davon aus, dass wir sie beantworten.
Wink doch mal.
Winken wir alle. Wir winken auch mal. Komisch, der Einzelne, der es wirklich macht, bin ich bereit.
Ach so.
Aber sie winken auch schon.
Barney hat gewinkt.
Und kriegt sich jetzt die ganze Nacht nicht mehr ein, weil er im Radio erwähnt worden ist.
Ja, freut sich schon.
Er sagt schon gar nichts mehr.
Ja, hier wird auch gleich wieder rumgepöbelt. JavaScript muss natürlich auch können, der Browser. Aber ich gehe mal davon aus, dass ein Framesfähiger Browser auch ein bisschen JavaScript kann.
Bisschen.
Schön, und da schmeißen wir wieder schon wieder mit Wörtern um uns.
Ja, wir können ja erstmal so ein bisschen die Hauspost erledigen. Es gibt ja auch bei uns auf der Webseite ein paar Neuigkeiten. Wer da öfter mal drauf rumklickt, dem dürfte aufgefallen sein, dass wir eine Sache radikal umgestellt haben. Also wenn man einen halbwegs modernen Browser benutzt, benutze diese Formulierung eigentlich sehr ungern. Also du weißt schon irgendwas, was immer mit so komischen hektigen Logos beworben wird, dass man das jetzt unbedingt haben muss.
Und auch fremd kann.
Und fremd kann, und fremd von JavaScript oder etwas, was sich zumindest so nennt. So, da wird man von uns gleich auf ein anderes Protokoll geschubst. Wer also mit HTTP ankommt, wird dann dezent darauf hingewiesen, dass wir dann doch lieber HTTPS machen würden. Also das ist dieses um SSL erweiterte HTTP, wo der eigentliche Datentransfer eben verschlüsselt ist. Und das tun wir im Wesentlichen deshalb, weil wir die Benutzung und auch den Bekanntheitsgrad von Kryptotechnologien aller Art eben fördern möchten, da wir gerade in der aktuellen Wahlkampfdiskussion und auch sonstigen Diskussionen, die weltweit und vor allem auch derzeit in Deutschland angehen, eben da ein großes Bedürfnis sehen, dieses zu tun. Praktisch hat das erstmal keinen Unterschied so für die Benutzung. Man kriegt nach wie vor die gleichen Seiten. Die sind auch nach wie vor öffentlich. Also es geht nicht darum, irgendwas zu verbergen, sondern es geht nur darum, den Transfer zu verschlüsseln. Dass zunächst einmal sich jeder darüber im Klaren wird, dass er sowas überhaupt auf seinem System hat und was das tut. Und natürlich dann auch, um so potenziellen Angriffen schon mal vorzubeugen, die vielleicht irgendwann mal auf uns zukommen oder auch auf andere Firmen, weil je Moment, wo eben so etwas durch Proxies durchläuft oder eben auch überhaupt durch Router durchläuft, unverschlüsselt, ist es relativ einfach machbar, Inhalte on the fly zu ändern. Das heißt, da kann irgendein Systembetreiber einfach vortäuschen, dass unsere Website einen bestimmten Inhalt hätte. Und um solche Dinge zu umgehen, machen wir zum Beispiel SSL.
Wird das langsam mal dadurch?
Ja, und SSL schützt auch nicht wirklich davor, dass da nicht irgendjemand dazwischen hängt. Das kann man mit viel Aufwand immer noch fecken. So ist das nicht. Aber SSL ist schon mal deswegen gut, weil jemand, der sich da ein bisschen vorbereitet hat, kann sich den Schlüssel angucken, indem er bei einem Skip zum Beispiel oben auf das Schloss klickt, was dann ein bisschen anders aussieht. Und dann kann er sich da angucken, wie er den Schlüssel unterschrieben hat, wer ihn erstellt hat und so eine Sache. Und auf die Art ist es jedenfalls möglich, schon mal Sachen zu verschlüsseln. Die Technologie ist ja seit Jahren verfügbar, aber frisst es so ein Schattendasein, weil viele Leute, das ist halt ein bisschen lästiger, und es dauert alles ein bisschen langsamer. Und das größte SSL-Problem ist, dass Caching-Proxy dadurch abgestellt wird. Und für viele Leute ist der Internetzugang überhaupt nur erträglich durch Cache-Proxys. Also es hat durchaus auch Nachteile. Was merkt man?
Nicht rasieren jetzt! Nicht rasieren, das kannst du ja hermachen.
Das ist ein ganz außergewöhnliches Gerät.
Wir machen hier gerade tagesaktuell, bereiten wir unser Doping vor.
Ich glaube es nicht.
Chaosradio Doping ist gut.
Es ist kein schöner Anblick.
Ich würde eine Sendung über Blumen machen.
Wir machen ein schönes Wort, um auf Frauen anzurufen.
Warum sind eigentlich Amiga-User immer so penetrante Großschreiber?
Das verhält sich immer proportional zum Bekanntheitsgrad und der Verbreitungskreise der eigenen Plattform.
Jetzt geht es wahrscheinlich hier gleich los, wenn man auch nur das Wort sagt.
Aber bleiben wir doch vielleicht noch mal kurz beim Thema. Beim HTTPS-Krypto. Letzten Endes geht es uns natürlich dabei nicht um SSL, sondern überhaupt um Kryptographie, insbesondere Mailverkehr. Derzeit gibt es ja so viele politische Diskussionen, dass man da vielleicht doch auch ganz offiziell mal in die E-Mail reingucken soll, weil ist ja alles ganz gefährlich, was da so abgeht derzeit auf dem Internet. Das Thema wollen wir heute allerdings nicht unbedingt vertiefen. Wer aber demnächst auf www.ccc.de guckt, soll sich da also nicht erschrecken. Alles ganz normal.
Und für den User sowieso eigentlich überhaupt kein Nachteil. Habt ihr denn nicht als Betreiber des Servers ein Interesse daran, auch ab und zu mal... Also bedeutet ein SSL für euch als Betreiber von so einem Server auch, dass ihr zum Beispiel nicht mehr sehen könnt, von welchen IPs die Leute kommen?
Doch, das kann man nur noch sehen. Das kann man sogar eher sehen als vorher, weil viele Leute für SSL kein Proxy eingetragen haben für HTTP, aber...
Das heißt aber auch, dass wenn jemand zum Beispiel, weiß ich nicht, der hat, weiß ich nicht, einen Internetzugang, der wo alles fertig eingerichtet war und der kommt auf eure Seiten und kriegt die nicht, dann hat er natürlich ein Problem. Da muss er irgendwie sein eventuell bestehendes Proxy abschalten.
Na, das kann nicht vorkommen. Also man trägt verschiedene Proxys ein für normales HTTP und für HTTPS. Und viele Leute haben halt in ihren Standard-Einstellungen einen Proxy für HTTP, aber keinen für HTTPS, weil sie gar nicht wissen, was das ist. Und es trägt man einen unter Security-Proxy und da weiß keiner, was das sein soll. Und wenn man den Provider fragt, der sagt dann normalerweise, das muss nicht sein, weil die Proxys in dem Fall tatsächlich nicht viel Gewinn bringen für den User. Das ist genauso langsam oder genauso schnell. Und deswegen kann es mal vorkommen, dass Leute, die hinter einer Firewall im Unternehmen sitzen, zum Beispiel, gar kein HTTPS machen können. Das ist dann natürlich schlecht. Und für uns kommt ganz konkret, hat das genießen, dass der Server erstmal geupgradet werden musste, weil Verschlüsselung kostet Rechenzeit und unser Server ist dann unter der Lot zusammengebrochen und wir mussten erstmal neue Hardware kaufen.
Sag mal, wo stellt man denn den HTTPS-Proxy ein? Weil wenn ich hier die Präferenzen von Netscape aufmache, da habe ich entweder direkte Connection oder manuelle oder automatische Proxy konfiguriert.
Also manuell ist das, was man auswählen muss. Und daneben ist ein View-Button oder ein Anzeigen im Deutschen.
Achso, und wenn ich eine automatische habe, dann ist HTTPS da nicht bei?
Doch, da stellt der Provider dann ein. Also da kann HTTPS auch bei sein, aber ist oft nicht.
Naja, also wenn es nicht klappt, dann ruft er an kurz hier. Und dann 0331110 und dann fragt er nochmal nach. Tim hat es gerade schon angedeutet, diese Umstellung der CCC Seiten auf SSL ist also eher ein Statement zur Zeit, ein politisches Statement als eine wirkliche Angst vor Angriffen.
Ja, vor allem weil uns das ja auch voll überhaupt nichts schützt und auch den Anwender nicht eigentlich vor etwas schützt, aber es geht halt darum, dass man Verschlüsselungen auch betreiben muss und man muss wissen, was man da macht, ansonsten sollte man das lieber lassen und insofern haben wir uns gedacht, wenn niemand dazu gezwungen ist, dann wird doch niemand das einsetzen, deswegen war das eben eher ein politisches Statement, als alles andere. Also Sicherheit auf dem Server ist für uns undenkbar.
Es ist auch so, wenn man SSL betreibt, dann verwendet man ja selber auch einen, korrigiert mich, einen Zert, man braucht sozusagen einen Schlüssel, mit dem man sich ja auch dann selber identifiziert, das heißt, man kann...
Also es gibt zwei, SSL Version 2 und 3. Und die Version 2, da authentifiziert sich erst mal nur der Server. Das heißt, das bringt uns überhaupt nichts als Serviceanbieter, aber der Kleine kann eben den an dem Schlüssel dann sehen, ob wir der Server sind, der wir behaupten zu sein. Und SSL Version 3 bietet vor Banken vor allem an, dass man auch als User ein Zertifikat haben kann. Das hat sogar eine Werbeaktion da mal gegeben von VeriSign. Das sind die offiziellen Herausgeber, wo man das umsonst kriegen konnte, für ein Jahr, und damit kann man auch seine E-Mail-Verschlüsselung mit netzcape. Also da gab es mal eine Aktion, und das geht auch, aber es weiß im Grunde fast niemand. Und wir haben erst mal angefangen damit, dass wir überhaupt Verschlüsselungen zulassen, um die Awareness ein bisschen zu steigern, oder auf Deutsch Akzeptanz. Wir möchten eben, dass das breite Volk mitkriegt, dass Verschlüsselungen überhaupt gehen, dass sie das schon haben, und dass es eigentlich gar nicht viel Aufwand ist. Also dass es im Grunde gar nicht weiter auffällt, wenn man einmal das gemacht hat.
Viel wichtiger für den Menschen zu Hause ist wahrscheinlich dann die E-Mail-Verschlüsselung. Geht es darum heute oder wollen wir da gar nicht kommen? Ach ja, wir wollen ja nicht sicher machen, wir wollen ja unsicher machen.
Das kommt vielleicht bei den Neuerungen nochmal zu bleiben und das dann auch abzuschließen. Wir haben auch noch spanische Hackerfreunde mit auf unseren Server genommen.
Asyl geboten.
Asyl geboten, die werden gerade ein bisschen verfolgt oder haben zumindest berechtigterweise ein bisschen Angst. Deswegen gibt es jetzt einen hisparhack.ccc.de, wer spanisch mächtig ist, der kann da gerne mal reingucken. Das ist wie gesagt nicht von uns, sondern von diesen Spaniern und wir hosten das nur, damit es eben auch außerhalb von Spanien ist und falls bei denen mal irgendwelche Leute in schusssicheren Westen reinlaufen, dann läuft er zumindest immer noch in Deutschland.
Kennt jemand die Szene in Spanien? Naja, mich nicken, Ja sagen, das Radio.
Also die Seiten sind ziemlich cool.
Also sie sehen optisch sehr ansprechend aus und was wir verstanden haben bzw. was Alter Wisdoms übersetzt hat, sah auch so aus, dass wir das unterstützen können.
Alter Wisdoms?
Was Alter Wisdoms übersetzt hat?
Natürlich ein bisschen vorsichtig.
Ist schon sehr coole.
Das gucke ich mir auch jetzt erstmal kurz an hier, das ist ja eine Livesendung, wie heißt es? Hac-Hispa-Hac-Hac-Hac-Hac-Hac-Hac-Hac-Hac-Hac-Hac-Hac-Hac-Hac-Hac-Hac-Hac-Hac-Hac-Hac-Hac-Hac-Hac-Hac-Hac-Hac-Hac-Hac-Hac-Hac-Hac-Hac-Hac-Hac-Hac-Hac-Hac-Hac-Hac-Hac-Hac-Hac-Hac-Hac-Hac-Hac-Hac-Hac-Hac-Hac-Hac-Hac-Hac-Hac-Hac-Hac-Hac-Hac-Hac-Hac-Hac-Hac-Hac-Hac-Hac-Hac-Hac-Hac-Hac-Hac-Hac-Hac- Das ist doch toll in der spanischen Sprache, oder? Wenn sie ein Fragezeichen vor uns heben.
Typografisches, richtiges, schönes kleines Gerät.
Wir kriegen hier gerade berichtet, vorsichtig sein, die Site stürzt irgendwelche Netzgeld schon ab.
Ah ja, super. Na ja, Hauptsache es sieht schick aus. Kurz.
Also seid vorsichtig. Wenn der Spanischen nicht ganz so mächtig ist, dann möchte sich vielleicht was deutsches angucken, was wir uns auf dem Server noch haben. Das ist sozusagen für unseren Mallorca Urlauber. Ja, jetzt fange ich nochmal an. Wer das Spanische nicht mächtig ist, der möchte sich vielleicht was anderes anschauen, was auf unserem FTP Server, auf ftp.ccc.de, rumliegt, nämlich die gescannte Version einer weitgehend vergriffenen Dokumentation zum Tod von Karl Koch, der vor neun Jahren zu der Ermittlung um einen KGB-Hack-Spionagefall ums Leben gekommen ist und dessen Lebensgeschichte wird in dieser Dokumentation beschrieben. Da das Ding sozusagen nicht mehr im Druck ist, haben wir es jetzt gescannt und man kann es sich von dort, von ftp.cc.de, herunterladen.
Genau, die Scans als Chip, also bereitet euch auf eine längere Session.
Ja, wir werden auch nochmal eine etwas kleinere Variante mit JPEGs machen. Dann ist es sozusagen auch für Leute mit etwas schmalerer Bandbreite sicherlich ergreiflich. Aber bei uns ging es erstmal darum, dass es überhaupt auf Mirrors kommt und so ein bisschen Verbreitung findet. Zumal eben die Geschichte von Karl Koch Grundlage ist eines Films, der Ende Oktober in die deutschen Kinos kommen wird, der den Namen 23 trägt und der sich eben schwerpunktmäßig mit dem Leben von Karl Koch auseinandersetzt und die Geschichte eben teilweise nach erzählt. Der Film hat einiges an Authentizität und setzt sich das erste Mal wirklich intensiv und mit einem gewissen Anspruch der Wahrheit nicht zu weit zu entkommen, mit diesem Thema auseinander und berührt eben sozusagen damit auch unsere Domäne.
Mehr zu diesem Thema nach dem Fritz-Kurz-Info, was gleich kommt. Eigentlich in einer Minute, aber wahrscheinlich schieben wir das ein bisschen nach hinten raus. Und mehr zu diesem Film, dann übrigens auch zu dem Zeitpunkt hier, weil das Chaos Radio sich natürlich mit diesem Film auseinandersetzen wird. Der hat Chaos Radio den Computer Blumen bei Fritz. Mit dem Chaos Computer Club. Super. Aber super, wenn die Musik zu Ende ist, eigentlich genau die richtige Möglichkeit, um dann auch das Fritz Kurzinfo zu machen. Schade, dass ich nicht genau wusste, wann die Musik zu Ende ist. Naja, macht ja jetzt Irina soweit klar?
Wenn Fritz im Raum Angermünde, dann 100, 1.
22.30 Uhr.
Eklat, die Tote France steht möglicherweise vor dem Abbruch. Die Fahrer reagierten heute auf das Vorgehen der Polizei im Zuge der Dopinganmittlungen mit einem Bummelstreik. Drei Teams stiegen auf der 149 Kilometer langen Etappe von Al-Bawil nach Aix-les-Vas aus dem Rennen aus. Die Behörden setzen trotz eines Ultimatums der Fahrer, die Polizeiaktionen einzustellen, ihre Untersuchungen mit Tappenzielaut fort. Ausweisung Ungeachtet der Kämpfe in der serbischen Unruhe Provinz Kosovo haben Nordrhein-Westfalen und Niedersachsen heute 93 Jugoslawen nach Belgrad abgeschoben. Darunter befinden sich auch Kosovo-Albaner. Rettungsarbeiten, eine dramatische Hilfsaktion für die verschütteten Bergleute im österreichischen Lassing ist heute vorerst gescheitert. Ein deutsches Team stieg in das Bergwerk ein, musste aber in einer Tiefe von 100 Metern aus Sicherheitsgründen abbrechen. Die zehn noch verschütteten Männer werden in rund 130 Metern vermutet. Gewalt. Vier junge Männer haben in Bernau einen Afrikaner überfallen. Sie stugen auf den 53-jährigen Mann aus Gambia ein und verletzten ihn schwer. Die als rechtsradikal bekannten 18- bis 25-jährigen Täter wurden vorläufig festgenommen. Gegen sie ist Haftbefehl beantragt worden. Freiheitsstrafe wegen Kindesmissbrauch muss ein Sexshop-Besitzer aus Wusterhausen für drei Jahre ins Gefängnis. Das Landgericht Neuropeen befand den 43-jährigen für schuldig, Jungen zwischen 12 und 15 Jahren mehrfach sexuell missbraucht und dabei fotografiert zu haben.
Wetter.
Abends und in der Nacht Schauer 16 bis 14 Grad, morgen gelegentlich Regen bis 25 Grad. Verkehr. Es liegen keine aktuellen Meldungen vor. Fritz wünscht gute Fahrt.
Es gibt ja so romantische Filme mit Happy End und so. Und Beziehungskomödien mit Till Schweiger und James Bond. Und Action mit Arnold Schwarzenegger.
Und es gibt Godzilla. Das Godzilla Filmfestival. Mit 12 unheimlich lange Zeit unsichtbar gewesenen, unglaublich unheimlichen Godzilla-Klassiker. In weiteren Hauptrollen, Dämonen aus dem Weltall, Ule Heue aus dem Meer, der Flugsauher oder King Kong und Frankensteins Helmhut. Das Godzilla Filmfestival. Vom 30. Juli bis zum 19. August, dem Movimento Kreuzberg und dem Blow-Up Frenzlauer Berg.
Präsentiert von Fritz.
Ich fahre jetzt weiter mit dem Chaos Radio der Computable Moon bei Fritz jeden letzten Mittwoch im Monat mit dem Chaos Computer Club und mit Johnny. Und natürlich mit euch entweder im www.chat unter www.fritz.de slash speakers oder im Telnet-Chat unter telnet www.ccc.de oder später per Telefon. Das Thema heute, Hacking The Internet, zum zweiten Mal Thema in dieser Sendereihe. Und übrigens heute Ausgabe Nummer 30 vom Chaos Radio.
Hör ich eigentlich.
Hacking The Internet heute das Thema. Ich hab gerade gesagt, komm lass uns ruhig ein, zwei Sätze noch zum Thema Hacker, der Hacker, die Hackerin sagen, weil für viele Leute ist ein Hacker jemand, der ihnen Geld klaut am Internet. Oder Kreditkarten, Nummern.
Naja, es gibt da ja ganz puristische Definitionen, die sagen, dass ein Hacker nur an der Technik interessiert ist und sich sozusagen auch nur um interessante Lösungen bemüht. In der wirklichen Welt sind natürlich Hacker auch am Leben beteiligt sozusagen. Das heißt, es macht ihnen auch Spaß, andere Leute Technik auszureizen, wenn sie die nun mal nicht selber haben.
Für mich persönlich sind Hacker ja die Leute, die immer wieder beweisen, dass das, was die großen Firmen erzählen, nicht unbedingt so stimmt.
Ja, das ist natürlich ein wichtiger Teil davon. Ein Großteil von unserem Leben ist, dass Leute uns Sachen erzählen, die wir nicht über Nacht prüfen können.
Im Radio und so?
Ja, zum Beispiel gibt es immer so Moderatoren im Radio, die uns Nachrichten vorlesen und die kann man nicht überprüfen. Ein paar Sachen kann man daneben überprüfen. Wenn man zu den Leuten gehört, die sich mit der Materie gut genug auskennen, um das zu widerlegen, dann sollten die das schon tun, am besten öffentlich.
Genau, ich denke vor allem, dieser öffentliche Aspekt ist der Punkt bei den Hacker. Das sind halt Leute, die davon überzeugt sind, dass ein Machterhalt nicht gut für alle ist, dadurch, dass man Informationen zurückhält. Machtpolitik, dadurch auszuheben, dass man Informationen zurückhält, das ist das, wogegen sich das Hacker-Tum wehrt. Wir sind eher davon beseelt, zu glauben, dass alles, was öffentlich ist in seinem Charakter, auch öffentlich sein sollte und das, was privat in seinem Charakter ist, geschützt sein sollte vor der Öffentlichkeit. Das sehen die Machthaber meistens immer genau andersrum. Die erzählen ja lieber nichts darüber, was sie selber machen, aber man soll ja am besten selber ein Ausweis schlicht haben, um sich in der Straße öffentlich mal in der Nase zu bohren. Das entspricht nicht wirklich unserer Überzeugung.
Eine Hacker-Kultur gibt es auf der ganzen Welt, selbst in Ländern, wo das Internet zum Beispiel lange noch nicht so ein Thema ist wie bei uns, nicht nur in der westlichen Welt.
Gerade in Osteuropa ist es so, dass da von den Leuten echt als Befreiung empfohlen wird, dass sie jetzt ein Medium haben, das nichts mit ihren finsten Realitäten vor Ort zu tun hat. Da sind auch viele Leute unterwegs, die mehr als die Hälfte ihres Monatseinkommens, was nur ein paar hundert Mark sind, dafür aufwenden, ihren Internetaccount zu finanzieren.
Ein Kopfhörer kurz vor dem Mikro, Pipe.
Die Hintergrundmusik ist eigentlich sehr leise, ich weiß es kaum.
Hi, mach mal lauter.
Du hast dich immer gleich übertreiben musst.
Naja, ich kenne halt nix dazwischen.
Hacking hat ja auch nicht unbedingt was mit Computern zu tun.
Man kann auch zu Tour de France hacken, in dem alle ganz langsam fahren.
Jetzt freut uns das auch ganz ungemein, wenn wir das hier in den Nachrichten haben. Aber hacken ist zum Beispiel auch, wenn jemand einen VW kauft und da 50 Leute reintritt, wo alle Leute sagen würden, das geht nicht. Und wenn man das dann sieht, dann legt man, na, das ist doch toll.
Naja, so toll ist der Anblick, glaube ich.
Wenn jemand Sachen demonstriert, die vorher für unmöglich gehalten wurden, dann ist das auch ein Hack.
Hacking gleich geht nicht, gibt's nicht. So, das ist doch hübsch, dann haben wir zumindest ein kleines Intro gegeben für die, die jetzt sagen hacken, hacken, hacken. Was ist das denn? Ist das eine Gartensendung? Hab schon wieder vergessen, nach was ich jetzt fragen sollte. Nach IPs Puff-Aid?
Ja, die müssen schon jetzt mal wieder ein bisschen brennen, ob Leute jetzt genug Späße gemacht haben. Das ist immerhin total ernst.
Ich finde die Sendung kann ja auch ein bisschen, ein bisschen, ein bisschen pep haben. Ach, die sind immer so ernst, die sind immer so ernst.
Nachmittag. Wir sind ernst? Na ja, Gott, wir sind doch nicht ernst.
Ja, nein.
Wie sind hier vier gesetzte ältere Menschen?
Wir sind jetzt dreißig geworden, alle gleichzeitig.
Stimmt.
Ja, wir können ja einfach mal anfangen, wenn du die richtigen Fragen nicht stellst.
IPs Puff-Aid, habe ich gerade gesagt schon. Sag mal, wer alles erklären kann, was eine IP ist, kann ja mal kurz anrufen. 0331 von Potsdam, 709711.
Nein, nein, nein, wir tun alles.
Na was denn? Warte doch mal. Siehst du, der kann es zum Beispiel schon mal nicht. Die Telefonleitungen sind leer, also ist die Frage nach der IP irgendwie gar nicht so blöd. Hallo, wer ist denn da?
Es gibt nicht die IP.
Johnny, du musst die Frage was erstellen.
Ich will das kürzlich IP erklärt haben.
IP steht für Internetprotokoll.
Genau, und was ist das? Hallo? Warte mal.
Was war das denn?
Hallo, wer ist denn da? Hallo, wer ist denn da?
Ah, siehst du Johnny, die haben immer recht.
Warte, sei mal mal, du musst halt reine Leise machen, sonst können wir dich nicht hören.
Warte, na, Internet-Protokoll-Adresse.
Was ist denn das?
Die Erkennungsadresse von dem PC.
Wir haben aber nach IP gefragt, nicht nach IP-Adresse. Hallo, wer ist denn da?
Hallo, wer ist denn da?
Hallo, wer ist denn da? Hallo, wer ist denn da? Hallo, wer ist denn da? Hallo, wer ist denn da? Hallo, wer ist denn da? Hallo, wer ist denn da? Hallo, wer ist denn da? Hallo, wer ist denn da? Hallo, wer ist denn da? Internet-Protokoll. Das ist das Protokoll, was im Internet verwendet wird, damit sich die Rechner miteinander unterhalten können. Damit die sich unterhalten können, müssen die ja wissen, wie sie ihre Zahlen da anzuordnen haben.
Jetzt bist du glücklichen zufrieden.
Hey, du machst hier eine Radiosendung. Da draußen sitzen 120.000 Leute pro Stunde.
Und einer von denen hat gerade gesagt, ich glaube, die im Studio sind auch nicht so helle.
Wahrscheinlich haben es mehrere gesagt. Aber von denen wissen garantiert mindestens 90.000 nicht, was IP ist. Ah gut, weiter.
Jetzt wissen Sie alles. Und jetzt werden wir auch gleich mal erklären, was ein Exploit ist.
Ja, ein Exploit, also Exploit, nein, also prinzipiell Exploit kommt aus dem Englischen und heißt, wenn man was ausnutzt. Und in dem Bereich, in dem wir uns heute bewegen mit der Sendung, geht es darum, dass man Sicherheitsschwachstellen in Systemen ausnutzt. Und ein IP-Exploit ist dann ein Exploit, der entweder Eigenschaften von IP oder IP-basierten Systemen ausnutzt. Und mit ausnutzen ist gar nicht unbedingt gemeint, dass man dann irgendwo Geld überweist oder irgendwelche Sachen kaputt macht, sondern im Grunde heißt es eben, dass man diese Sache benutzt, um irgendetwas zu machen, was ursprünglich nicht gedacht war. Also zum Beispiel, dass ich zeigen kann, dass ich mehr machen darf, als ich als Anonymer User machen dürfte. Zum Beispiel, normalerweise darf ein Anonymer User gar nichts machen bei Servern. Da muss zum Beispiel bei einer Bank ein Kunde sein. Und wenn ich jetzt bei einer Bank über das Internet mir Geld überweisen kann oder auch nur einen Kontostand von jemandem ansehen kann, dann wäre das zum Beispiel ein IP-Exploit.
Wobei das schon ein relativ komplexer Exploit wäre. Grundsätzlich versteht man eben, es gibt Web-Server im Netz, zum Beispiel www.routeshale.com, der populärste. Da gibt es auch noch ein paar andere. Die haben eine Exploit-Database, haben also eine große Datenbank, wo sie im Prinzip Angriffe, Attacken auf irgendwelche Computersysteme drin speichern, dokumentieren, auf welche Art und Weise das vor sich geht. Und die IP-Exploits haben natürlich im Internet eine besondere Bedeutung, weil man kann im Prinzip Systeme aus dem Tritt bringen, auf die viel verschiedensten Arten und Weisen, nur indem man eben mit diesen Systemen anders spricht, als sie es normalerweise erwarten. So ungefähr so, als ob wenn ich jetzt irgendwie hinter jedes dritte Wort irgendwie noch ein Ups rein setze, dass du dann irgendwann anfängst, hier einen Kreis zu tanzen, einen roten Kopf zu kriegen und am Schluss aus dem Fenster zu springen. So in etwa ist das. Normalerweise tut man ja sowas nicht, aber da ja irgendwie viele Computer relativ schlecht programmiert sind, das sind eigentlich fast alle, so befinden sich eben dermaßen viele Schwachstellen in dem Code, der Internetprotokoll spricht, dass diese Systeme wirklich sehr angreifbar sind. Das ist jetzt nicht nur so irgendwie so eine Marotte, dass das mal hier geht und mal da geht, sondern man kann eigentlich davon ausgehen, dass so eigentlich fast alle Systeme irgendwie ein Problem haben. Und wenn man jetzt irgendwie bewusst auf ein bestimmtes System mal losgehen möchte und das mal aus dem Tritt bringen möchte, dann ist das ein sehr kurzer Weg, um das zu erreichen. Allein schon deshalb, weil so viele Windows NT benutzen.
Also sind ja nicht nur Sachen, die halt wegen schlechter Programmierung oder ähnlichen Dingen da drin sind, sondern oft genug sind es halt auch richtige Hintertüren, die da absichtlich drin gelassen wurden, entweder von den Programmierern oder halt, wenn irgendwelche Leute ein Interesse dran haben. Also viele von den Sachen, die man so findet, da fragt man sich doch echt irgendwie, ist es tatsächlich jetzt irgendwie nur schlampege Programmierung oder hat sich da jemand eine schöne Hintertür reingezumalten?
Gib doch mal ein paar praktische Beispiele, was man damit dann anstellen könnte.
Na ja, in letzter Zeit besonders häufig gewesen sind Routerprobleme und Router ist jetzt die Basis, auf der das Internet und überhaupt IP-basierte Netzwerke zusammenarbeiten. Der Router ist einfach ein Rechner, der dafür sorgt, dass verschiedene lokale Netzwerke miteinander reden können. Und ein Router koppelt also kleine Rechnernetze zusammen, die an sich schon miteinander reden können. Aber wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel mit einer Filiale in der Schweiz reden möchte, dann ist klar, dass ich da nicht einfach direkt ein Kabel hingelegt habe, sondern es geht dann über ein Telefonnetz oder so etwas, oder ein anderes Kabel von meinem Provider. Und an der Koppelstelle sitzt ein Router, der das macht. Und Router gibt es von vielen, vielen Firmen. Der Marktführer ist Cisco. Die haben irgendwie über 80 Prozent der Internet-Backbones am Cisco-Router in Verwendung. Und es gibt aber auch andere. Da kann man ja keine Werbung machen. Also 3Comb, BayNetworks, Ascent, da gibt es einige. Und da ist in letzter Zeit eine wahre Welle rausgekommen von dokumentierten Hintertüren und so richtig Sachen, die möglicherweise gar nicht mal böse gemeint sind. Also du kannst mir schon vorstellen, dass bei einer Routerfirma der User anruft und sagt, ich habe aber mein Passwort vergessen. Was mache ich denn jetzt? Und dann wäre das natürlich schlecht, wenn die Firma sagen müsste, schicken sie mal den Router her, weil dann müsste man ja Service leisten. Und deswegen ist das für die billiger, deine Hintertür einzubauen, damit sie eben immer rankommen. Und so eine Sachen sind eben zunehmend gefunden worden, weil eben auch danach gesucht wurde. Und weil das Passwort dann aber auch so richtig blöd, einfach, lernbar oder einfach ausprobierbar war, so Sachen wie Debug oder Technik oder... Also Hintertür direkt hieß es dann nicht. Also im Grunde, so eine Sachen sind wirklich alarmierend, häufig in letzter Zeit aufgetaucht.
Aber was passiert denn, wenn ich jetzt durch so eine Hintertür an so einen Router rankomme? Vorausgleich, ich habe überhaupt keine Ahnung, was ich da machen soll.
Ja, das ist immer die Basis von IP überhaupt exploits. Also, dass man echt weiß, wovon man spricht. Also, nehmen wir mal an, ich bin jetzt ein böser Hacker und möchte in eine Bank einbrechen. Dann hat diese Bank wahrscheinlich eine Firewall installiert und in Firewalls sind Konfigurationen von Rechnern, in denen gewöhnlich mindestens ein oder zwei Router konfiguriert sind oder Rechner Routerfunktionen übernehmen. Und die können zusätzlich noch bestimmte Pakete wegfiltern. Und darauf basiert die Sicherheit, dass ich weiß, welche Dienste ich erlauben möchte. Zum Beispiel Webserver, der soll von außen erreichbar sein, aber irgendwelche anderen unsicheren Dienste, die sollen halt gar nicht erst durch den Router durchkommen. Und wenn der Router jetzt eine Hintertür hat und meine Firma verlässt sich darauf, dass Angriffe auf irgendeinen bekannten unsicheren Dienst durch den Router weggefiltert werden, dann kann ich eben dem Router sagen, ja, aber mich lass mal durch. Und schon ist die Firma in meiner Gewalt sozusagen.
Was heißt unsichere Dienste? Was ist dann FTP oder Telnet oder was weiß ich?
Ja, FTP zum Beispiel wird von vielen Firmen oder überhaupt Sides als unsicher betrachtet, weil eben Passwörter im Klartext über das Netz gehen. Und wenn man möchte jetzt nicht, dass der Chef sich von irgendwo einloggen kann und dein Hacker hat auf dem Weg dann das Passwort mitgelesen und kann sich dann auch einloggen als der Chef. Deswegen FTP wird gerne weggefiltert oder Telnet auch. Also und IRC und andere Dienste haben ja sowieso den Ruf, sowieso nur von Hackern benutzt zu werden. Und so eine Sachen möchte man halt rausfiltern. Oder überhaupt Sachen, E-Mail zum Beispiel, dass Leute remote ihre E-Mail lesen können mit Netzcab. Dann benutzt man Protokolle wie POP oder IMAP und die möchte man auch gerne rausfiltern am Router. Also das klingt jetzt so, als wenn es ein sehr spezielles Problem ist, aber fast alle Firmen, die am Internet hängen, benutzen Router an einer Stelle, um Pakete wegzufiltern. Und wenn da eine Hintertür drin ist im Router, ist das echt schlecht. Und die Firmen, die ich vorhin genannt habe und noch eine andere Firma namens N-Base, die unter anderem OEM-Router herstellen für Intel und Gigital und noch ein paar andere Firmen sind, in letzter Zeit davon betroffen gewesen. Also im Grunde, eine Nachricht, die man in den letzten Monaten hat lernen können oder Wochen, ist einfach, Routern darf man nicht trauen. Man muss zusätzlich Maßnahmen ergreifen, um seine Rechner und Netze sicher zu machen.
Ein Problem ist eben dabei auch, dass die interne Sicherheit in den meisten Firmen wesentlich niedriger angesiedelt ist als die Sicherheit gegen das Internet. Das heißt, nach außen hin werden Abwehrmaßnahmen betroffen, dass da nicht jeder an die internen Sachen rankommt. Aber intern herrscht bei den kleineren Firmen, die ich so kenne, eine extrem große Freizügigkeit. Insofern ist das dann schon geschäftsschädigend, wenn man da reinkommt. Das ist also durchaus gefährlich, wenn Daten irgendwie einfach gelöscht werden können, Dinge in diese Richtung.
Die Gefahr basiert jetzt nicht nur darauf, dass der Router unsicher ist, sondern man muss als Firma anderen Leuten auch vertrauen, unter anderem seinem Internetprovider, dass er die E-Mails nicht an andere Leute weitergibt. So vertraut man unter anderem oft kleineren Firmen, die man die Sicherheit aushaust. Das wird häufig gemacht von größeren Firmen, dass sie eine andere Firma damit beauftragen, ihren Internetzugang zu machen und auch sicher zu halten. Solche Firmen können natürlich auch hinter Türen sich einbauen und das als Wartungszugang bezeichnen. Das wird häufig gemacht. Viele Leute, die es nicht besser wissen, betrachten es dann auch als Feature, dass die Firma, wenn ein Problem ist, sich dann einwählen kann. Aber im Grunde ist es eine Hintertür im klassischen Sinne. Wenn jetzt die Konkurrenz dafür Geld ausgibt und weiß, welche Firma man beauftragt hat, dann ist das eine Sache von Minuten einzubrechen, obwohl man da möglicherweise sehr viel Geld für die Sicherheit ausgegeben hat.
Ich wollte gerade fragen, ist Geld nicht auch ein Kostenfaktor? Du hast als Firma Firewall und so gut wie du es weißt, alles abgesichert. Jetzt sagt dir jemand, die Router haben aber alle Hintertürchen von Firma XY. Da hat man in letzter Zeit viel gelesen. Was machst du als nächstes? Setzt du noch einen Router hin von einer anderen Firma?
Ja, das kommt drauf an. Prinzipiell ist es mit Firewalls wie mit allen Sachen im Leben. Man sollte es nur Leute machen lassen, die sich damit ausgehen. Es hilft nichts, sich mal kurz ein Buch von Data Becker zu holen. Da steht drin, Firewall ist, wenn der Router so und so macht. Man muss da Leute beauftragen, die sich auskennen. Wenn man sicher gehen will und sich das leisten kann, sollte man noch eine zweite Firma damit beauftragen, die Installation der ersten Firma auf ihre Sicherheit zu überprüfen. Die hat vollen Eingriff und soll dann sagen, ob sie das hätte besser machen können oder nicht.
Macht ihr sowas eigentlich? Gibt es Firmen, die zu euch kommen und sagen, wir haben hier ein Firewall errichtet und würden wissen, ob der wirklich sicher ist? Könnt ihr euch da mal eine Woche mit auseinandersetzen?
Das gibt es immer wieder regelmäßig. Und den schicken wir dann auch immer wieder die Standardantwort. Die lautet, der Chaos Computer Club tut so etwas nicht als Chaos Computer Club. Es hängt dann sehr von der Anfrage ab, was das so für Leute sind und wie die so gemeint ist. Man kann ja auch ein bisschen zwischen den Zeilen lesen. Es gibt auch durchaus gut gemeinte Anfragen, wofür Firmen ein konkretes Problem haben. Und da verweisen wir dann einfach auf Unternehmen, denen wir nicht besonders misstrauisch gegenüberstehen, von denen wir das Gefühl haben, dass sie das handeln können. Aber das ist dann private Geschichte und das hat nichts mit dem Chaos Computer Club zu tun. Aber wir sind auch nicht wirklich ein Vermittlungsbüro für solche Anfragen. Also es hängt dann wirklich vom Fall ab.
Das klingt jetzt vielleicht so, als wenn es nicht vorkommt, dass irgendwie bös gemeinte Anfragen kommen. Aber gerade in letzter Zeit ist so ein Fall gewesen, den wir in der letzten Datenschleuder kurz beschrieben haben, wo ein Hacker angesprochen wurde, er möge doch mal bitte eine Firma überprüfen. Und der Auftrag kam von einer ganz anderen Firma, die von sich gesagt hat, sie sei doch eine Consulting-Firma, die eben den Auftrag von der anderen Firma hätte. Und am Ende stellt sich eben raus, dass das von einem Nachrichtendienst ausging und dass ein Hacker hier benutzt wurde, um das zu spielen.
Also eine deutsche Behörde und wahrscheinlich etwas merkwürdig. Zumal der Auftrag darin bestand, eine Auslandsaufklärung zu betreiben. Und das halte ich schon für etwas zweifelter.
Also sowas kommt durchaus vor und wird auch immer wieder gerne an uns herangetrieben, dass irgendwelche Leute uns fragen, ob wir das nicht machen können.
Wir sind erwachsam, wir kennen die Tricks.
Hier hört Chaosradio, die Sendung mit den meisten Abkürzungen der Welt.
Zumal bei Fritz.
So, jetzt reden wir über DOS.
Was?
Denial of Service, ne?
Ja, vielleicht mal kurz nochmal zu den Hintertürchen. Wie findet man denn eine in einem Router?
Ja, Router ist jetzt ein spezielles Beispiel, aber ein Router ist ja zwar ein Stück Hardware, was man kauft, was integriert ist, aber da läuft natürlich am Ende auch ein Prozessor drauf und der hat auch Software. Hintertürnen in Routern findet man, wie in anderer Software, dass man erstmal natürlich das Problem hat, dass die Software auf irgendeinem Chip drauf ist, ein EEPROM gewöhnlich oder ein Flashrom. Und das kann man natürlich extrahieren, wenn man den Router aufschraubt und dann ein bisschen umfummelt. Und dann kann man da eine ganz plumpe Suche bringen, indem man Sachen, die nach Text aussehen, raussucht und dann guckt, ob das vielleicht so aussieht, als wenn es ein Passwort sein könnte. Und da kommen dann so Sachen raus wie Technician oder Debug. Und dann kann man sich überlegen, ob man das nicht mal ausprobiert. Und es ist am Ende viel Probieren und auch Glückssache. Aber so werden oft Sachen gefunden. Natürlich eine andere Möglichkeit ist, dass irgendein verärgerter Mitarbeiter der Firma irgendwann sagt, ja, ich kündige und außerdem veröffentliche jetzt mal die Hintertüren, die ich gerne. Und Hintertüren, es ist nicht unbedingt so, dass die Firma das böse meinte, das habe ich vorhin schon gesagt. Aber Firmen, die in den USA sitzen, haben zum Beispiel ein Gesetz, das ihnen vorschreibt, die Sachen erst dann exportieren zu dürfen, wenn sich der Geheimdienst das angesehen hat. In Amerika ist das die NSA. Und wenn die sagen, ihr dürft das nur exportieren mit diesem Code, dann müssen wir das eben tun. Und so ist historisch im Cisco-Router eine Hintertür reingekommen, über die die Europäische Union abgehört wurde. Dieser Fall ist dann auch herausgekommen und es läuft gerade eine Untersuchung. Deswegen, eine formelle Anhörung ist schon geschehen. Und wir dürfen da gespannt mit der Dinge haren, die dann passieren. Aber die Hintertüren finden sich natürlich nicht selber und stehen noch nicht in der Hilfedatei, das ist völlig klar.
Rieb mich!
Und im Handbuch auch nicht, ja genau. Deswegen kommen die auch relativ selten raus. Also wenn es da irgendwie ein Standardverfahren gäbe, jetzt suchen wir nach Hintertüren, dann hätten wir das ja schon längst alles gefunden, aber so einfach ist das natürlich nicht.
Wie war es mit Die Nerd of Service? Heißt das eigentlich Router oder Router? Es müsste da Router heißen.
Also es hängt von dem Land ab. Die Amis sagen ganz gern Router, in Deutschland sagt man ganz gern Router.
Aber die sagen aber auch nicht...
In England ist es halt anders.
Ach, ich verlasse mich auf die Engländer, die sprechen das bessere Englisch.
British Hackish nennt sich das dann. Commonwealth Hackish. Das ist dann der andere Slang. Die sprechen einiges ein bisschen anders aus. Aber die Unterschiede sind nicht besonders groß. Du kannst Router und Router sagen.
Ich sag Router.
Naja, also neben den Hintertüren gibt es dann natürlich auch die Möglichkeit, selber in eine Tür einzutreten, die vielleicht auch vorher noch gar nicht da gewesen ist. Die Maschinen nämlich auf eine Art und Weise aus dem Tritt zu kriegen, wie das sich die Programmierer vorher auch nicht gedacht haben. Also eine real existierende Hintertür ist ja sozusagen konkret von einem Programmierer mal hingelegt worden, um dann vielleicht von ihm selber gebraucht zu werden oder von irgendeinem alarmierten Kunden jetzt mal beruhigt werden muss. Es hat sich dann allerdings auch gezeigt, dass diese Systeme auf eine ganz andere Art und Weise aus dem Tritt zu bringen sind. Das ist das, was man dann auch ganz gerne unter Denial-of-Service-Attacken versteht. Also eine Attacke, die über das Internet kommt und die auf das betroffene System eben die Auswirkungen hat, dass es nicht mehr in der Lage ist, den Dienst, den es anbietet, weiterhin anzubieten. Da gibt es dann erst mal so Klassiker, dass man einfach die Maschine erst mal flutet, so mit irgendwelchen Paketen und dann weiß man eben die Softwareinversion sowieso, die reagiert halt auf das Ankommen von vielen Paketen von dem und dem Typ eben so chaotisch, dass es halt irgendwie abstürzt und es die Maschine einfach breit.
Das wird in letzter Zeit geholfen mit Druckern auch, weil Drucker einfach sind nicht darauf programmiert, die tollen Server zu sein und nicht für hohe Last. Da kommt halt ab und zu mal ein bisschen Druck an.
Na ja, klar.
Aber wenn jetzt eine Firma eine Deadline hat und bis morgen müssen diese 1000 Briefe raus, dann kann das durchaus ein Problem werden, wenn einer der Mitarbeiter sich mal einen Spaß draus macht, den Guter runterzufahren. Und jetzt klingt das vielleicht so, ich sage jedes dritte Wort ein Eu oder was hier vorhin als Beispiel kam. Computerprotokolle sind natürlich deutlich besser formalisiert und spezifiziert als menschliche Sprache, die ja doch redundant ausgelegt ist und man kann es so und so formulieren. Es ist aber so, dass gewöhnlich manche Programmierfehler sind einfach dokumentiert geworden im Laufe der Jahre. Manche Sprachen eignen sich eben dazu, bestimmte Fehler zu machen. Und so hat C einfach zwei, drei Fehler, die immer wieder gemacht werden, weil die Standard Library Funktionen nicht vorsehen, dass man sich einfach dagegen schützen kann. Und so kommt es zum Beispiel vor, dass viele Protokolle vorsehen, dass man sich meldet und erst mal sagt, wer man ist. Also man loggt sich ein, sagt seinen Usernamen oder man sagt, wie der Rechner heißt, von dem man kommt. Und an dieser Stelle wird natürlich erwartet, dass man so, weiß ich, fünf Zeichen, vielleicht zehn eingibt. Und deswegen reserviert das Programm für die Eingabe möglicherweise 100, um auch wirklich alle Fälle abzudecken. Aber wenn jetzt ein böser Hacker kommt, der kann auch 1000 eingeben. Und wenn das Programm eben nicht speziell dagegen geschützt ist, nach 100 abzubrechen, dann nennt man sowas einen Buffer Overflow. Und wenn man jetzt ein Programmierdetail macht, was häufig benutzt wird, nämlich dass der Buffer auf dem Stack liegt, das heißt innerhalb der Prozedur definiert ist, die ihn beschreibt, dann ist so ein Einbruch von außen möglich, sodass man dafür sorgt, dass spezieller Code ausgeführt wird, den man eben mit dieser langen, zu langen Eingabe mitgibt.
Also mit anderen Worten, man ist sozusagen in der Lage, die Daten, die man über das Internet an den Rechner schickt, wenn man sie geschickt schickt, so zu machen, dass man im Prinzip Programmcode überträgt, der danach durch diesen auftretenden Fehler auch ausgeführt wird. Und dann hat man im Real die Möglichkeit, sich auch eine Tür aufzumachen, weil man im Prinzip die Maschine von außen programmieren kann. Nur an einer ganz bestimmten Stelle, aber das reicht häufig genug, um einfach so den Klassiker zu machen, dass man sich nämlich in irgendeiner Form eine Tür aufstößt, über die man dann im zweiten Schritt bequem einfach reinmarschieren kann. Und wenn man erstmal auf dem Rechner ist, dann kann man meistens alles machen.
Also der Klassiker für was man macht in so einem Fall als Hacker, ist, dass man sich auf Unix-Servern eine Shell geben lässt. Und deswegen heißt das Stück Code, was man dem Server übergibt, um ihm Code ausführen zu lassen, auch Shell-Code gewöhnlich. Auch wenn es da andere Sachen gibt, jetzt gab es gerade jemanden, der sich dann Spaß gemacht hat, ein paar Shell-Codes zu machen, zum Beispiel um eine Maschine zu booten oder so. Dieser Code ist vollständig rechner- und systemabhängig. Das heißt, wenn irgendein zufälliger Hacker kommt und nicht weiß, was das für ein Server ist, den er da gerade angreift, dann ist es richtig schwierig, da so eine Attacke gegenzustarten. Deswegen ist es unter anderem wichtig, dass man dafür sorgt, dass es von außen nicht einfach erkennbar ist, um was für eine Maschine es sich handelt, was für eine Art Server-Software drauf läuft, solche Sachen. Und das ist einer der Gründe, warum heutzutage alle möglichen Programme darauf untersucht werden, ob sie von außen eine Versionsabfrage möglich machen. Also Sendmail ist zum Beispiel einer der Dienste, der seit ungefähr 20 Jahren ständig ein Sicherheitsproblem nach dem anderen herausgebracht hat. Und das erste, was man als Programmierer, also als Hacker tut, ist natürlich gucken, läuft da eine Sendmail-Version, die ich kenne und wo ich ein Problem kenne. Und wenn man zu Sendmail hingeht, den Server einfach anspricht, dann sagt er als erstes eine Version und das ist schon mal schlecht. Und deswegen gibt es viele Server, wo man das rausgemacht hat, diese Versionsabfrage. Und bei Sendmail kann man einstellen, inzwischen, was er da sagt. Also man kann zum Beispiel Sendmail so konfigurieren, dass er eine Version nennt, die es nicht gibt oder sich als was anderes ausgibt.
Naja, wobei, ich meine, das bringt natürlich keine tatsächliche Sicherheit. Das ist nur ein pragmatischer Weg, um sich gegen irgendwelche Spinner zu schützen, die einen Katalog haben von Versionsnummer zu Hack-Bombe und durch die Gegend Gehen und Mist machen. Aber genau genommen hat das natürlich mit Sicherheit nichts zu tun.
Na klar, aber es ist ein erster Schritt.
Aber es ist auf jeden Fall auch der klassische Interneteinbruch. Ich erinnere mich noch das erste Mal, dass das Internet als solches überhaupt in den Medien Echo gefunden hat. Wie lange ist das jetzt her? 10 Jahre mit dem Internetworm. Da gab es halt eine Hack-Attacke, lustigerweise von dem Sohn eines Sicherheitschefs, glaube ich, bei der APA oder NSA. Der hat halt ein bisschen rumgespielt und auch gerade mit Sendmail auf Sun-Maschinen ein bisschen umgeguckt. Hat dann so ein Programm geschrieben, ist auch ein bisschen getestet und er war noch eigentlich gar nicht so richtig da, wo er hin wollte. Da ist ihm das Programm irgendwie selbst ausgebürgst, hat einfach angefangen, die erste Maschine irgendwie zu attackieren, sich dort hinein zu implantieren. Deswegen spricht man eben auch von einem Worm, das ist kein Virus. Also ein Worm ist ein Programm, das sich selber irgendwie im Netz immer wieder von Maschine zu Maschine weiter trägt und dort wieder aktiv zu werden, um wieder weiter zu marschieren. Und dieses Programm hat halt innerhalb von wenigen Stunden im Prinzip das gesamte damalige Internet, was schwerwiegend aus Sun Workstations bestand, irgendwie breit gemacht. Sie hatten da wirklich ein richtiges Problem und es ist das erste Mal, dass wirklich das bekannt geworden ist. Diese Fehler, die damals schon im Internetwurm die Türen geöffnet haben, die gibt es heute noch tonnenweise. Also das ist nicht irgendwie ein bisschen ein Problem, sondern das ist einfach omnipräsent dieses Problem.
Übrigens dazu mal eine kleine Erweiterung. Es ist schon allen Beteiligten auch klar, dass wir hier ein Problem haben. Und es ist ja auch nicht so, dass die Leute absichtlich ihre Software schlecht schreiben. Die machen das auch nicht, um uns zu ärgern, sondern manche Leute machen das eben, um dann die nächste Version zu verkaufen, wenn wir keine Namen nennen hier. Und andere Leute machen das eben, weil sie alten Code benutzen und keine Zeit gefunden haben oder weil es auch keine gute Methode gibt, den Code...
Der RTCP-IP-Stack von NT.
Ja, bei Software gibt es auch keine richtig gute Methode, nach Sicherheitsproblemen zu suchen. Es sei denn man, also am besten noch automatisiert, das wäre natürlich das schönste, was es geben könnte, aber das gibt es eben nicht. Und da kommt man nicht drum herum, sich den Code wirklich Teile für Teile anzusehen, am besten von jeweils zwei verschiedenen Leuten. Und die suchen dann eben nach Sicherheitsproblemen. Und manche Leute machen das eben und andere eben nicht. Im Moment ist so ein Projekt gerade gegründet für Linux, wird bezahlt von Red Hat, weil die einfach genug Kohle gemacht haben, um es jetzt leisten zu können. Da haben ein paar Leute eingestellt, die auch recht kompetent sind und die machen das eben. Und auf der BSD-Seite gibt es sowas auch. Da gibt es OpenBSDs gegründet worden, aus diesem Grund unter anderem. Aber es gibt es natürlich auch für andere Systeme. Das Problem ist eben, bei freier Software ist es sicher nicht so ein Thema, da Leute zu finden, die diese Aufgabe machen. Es ist keine schöne Aufgabe, sich andere Leute Software anzugucken. Das ist sogar so eklig, dass es normalerweise teurer ist, Software selber zu schreiben als einen Code von anderen Leuten zu kaufen oder anders zu kriegen und weiter zu verwenden. Und Hersteller wie Sun oder IBM, die müssen eben Leute einstellen, die das machen. Und wenn man von Geld motiviert wird, dann ist das eine deutlich schlechtere Motivation, als wenn man das macht, weil man das eben selber gerne gelöst sieht, das Problem.
Dazu kann man aber sagen, dass die Verbreitung von Software, wo der Quellcode offen liegt, schon Mittel dazu beiträgt, dass mehr Sicherheitslücken jetzt inzwischen aufgedeckt werden. Es ist halt so, dass große Teile des Internets inzwischen auf Software basieren, die im Quellcode vorliegt und wo man zumindest theoretisch die Möglichkeit hat, einfach nachzuschauen, was da passiert. Also praktisch ist es natürlich schwierig, weil man muss erst mal jemanden kennenlernen, der in der Lage ist, solchen Code zu verstehen oder es eben selber können. Aber es führt eben zu einer wesentlich größeren Verbreitung von Wissen über Sicherheit und auch über Sicherheitslücken, was schon mal ein ganz positiver Effekt ist.
Eine hübsche Geschichte bei diesem Wafferoberflur ist natürlich noch die Kombination von Bugs. Da hat jemand diesen hübschen Wafferoberflur, der dann einen Brack im Pentium ausnutzt, der die Maschine komplett zum Stehen braucht, dass man sie, man musste sie sogar so hart resetten, damit sie wieder hoch kam.
Also ausschalten, einschalten.
Richtig.
Und, naja, also solche Bugs werden dann auch gerne kombiniert. Also diese Wafferoberflur-Exploits zu bauen, ist eine richtige, dolle Kunst. Da muss man wirklich wissen, was passiert. Zum Beispiel hat man das Problem, dass man einen Code verfassen muss, in dem keine Blue Bites vorkommen. Und, naja, jeder, der Assembler gemacht hat, mal reingeguckt hat, was da so rauskommt, wird wissen, dass es nicht so ganz einfach ist, sich zu tun.
Und deswegen besteht in Buffer Overflow normalerweise auch daraus, der Shell-Code besteht daraus, da einen kleinen D-Krypte zu haben. Wir haben also den Code irgendwie mit irgendwas gexhort oder irgendwie transformiert, damit keine Null Bites vorkommen und dann ist ein bisschen Wins Code vor, der diese Transformation rückgängig macht. Also das ist eine echte Kunst, sowas zu machen, und das können auf Erden auch nicht viele Leute. Aber wenn für eine Plattform...
Aber auch nicht wenige Leute.
Das kann fast niemand, aber...
Das kann nur Leute mit massig Zeit, also Schüler, Studenten.
Jemand, der Scanning Code veröffentlicht hat, kann man den natürlich wiederverwenden. Aber wenn für eine Plattform kein Shell-Code existiert, ist es echt schwierig, einen zu generieren. Und diesen Effekt hat man wunderbar bei AIX gesehen, das ist das Unix von IBM. Da ist irgendwann mal jemand gekommen und hat gesagt, also er hat jetzt mal ein Shell-Code gemacht für AIX auf Power-PCs. Und in den nächsten zwei Wochen sind ungefähr 60 Exploits veröffentlicht worden. Also dass dieser Shell-Code einfach sobald der da ist, ist es kein Problem mehr, den zu Hause zu benutzen. Und das ist einfach eine Sache. Obsturity hilft nicht wirklich gegen Sicherheitsprobleme. Viele Leute glauben einfach, sie können Pro-Sicherheitsprobleme lösen, indem sie die Sachen eben gut verstecken, irgendwie so im Wald eingraben, und dann sind ihre Daten halt sicher.
Vielleicht nochmal kurz ein bisschen allgemeiner zu werden, was da eigentlich gerade passiert. Computersysteme mussten das erste Mal geschützt werden, wo mehrere Leute einen Computer gleichzeitig benutzt haben, wo mehrere Leute gemeinsame Dateien benutzt haben. Typischerweise die ersten Unix-Systeme. Da kam überhaupt erst mal dieses Problem auf, dass man sich gegen irgendjemand anderes absichern muss. Das wurde durch bestimmte Sicherheitsmaßnahmen auch gewährleistet. Nur, dass man auf einem Unix-System ohne, dass es irgendwas mit Internet zu tun hat, schon mal kräftig loshacken kann. Da kommt eigentlich auch die Hackerei her. Und nach außen hin ist so ein System zunächst einmal recht sicher. Gehen wir mal aus, dass der Rechner in einem abgeschlossenen Rechnerraum steht. Man hat nur ein Terminal, man muss einen Benutzernamen und einen Kennwort eingeben. Dann ist dieses System natürlich eigentlich schon mal recht gut geschützt. Jetzt, wo allerdings alle Leute anfangen, ihren Computer untereinander zu vernetzen, vor allem mit TCPIP, schafft man einen zweiten Zugangsort zu dem Rechner, der eben nicht nur in einem Terminal besteht, also da, wo man auch physikalisch ran kann, sondern das geht dann auch übers Netz. Und im Internet eben dann von jedem Computer auf diesem Planeten. Und das vergrößert natürlich irgendwie die Zahl der Leute, die potenzielle Angreifer sein können, extrem. Und jetzt schaut man sich mal IP an. Das ist nicht so entwickelt worden, dass das irgendwie alles erstmal sicher ist oder so. Da hat einfach überhaupt niemand nachgedacht am Anfang. Es ging erstmal darum, dass das überhaupt funktionierte. Und diese ersten Ansätze mit IP, die halt dann ganz gut funktioniert haben, das ist heute der Standard. Da ist nicht viel dran gemacht worden, bevor das in die Medien ging. Auf einmal schrien sie alle Internet, Internet, Internet, Toll und bunt und Bilder und man kann auch klicken, das versteht ja jeder. Und dann meinten halt alle so, naja, dann machen wir halt jetzt TCP-IP. Super, ist ja auch zunächst einmal keine schlechte Idee. Nur jetzt stehen wir eben da und haben richtig dicke fette Löcher in allen Computern. Was auch nicht das Problem wäre, nur dass eben jetzt alle halt anfangen, wirklich kritische Dinge auf diesen Computern zu speichern. Transaktionen von Banken, Datenbanken, die irgendwelche wichtigen Personeninformationen enthalten und so weiter und so weiter. Und es gibt ja auch schon einen Zwang zur Vernetzung. Die Leute wollen bestimmte Informationen über das Internet bekommen. Also sind sie auch alle da, nur das abzusichern, ist eben sehr schwierig. Und der technisch Versierte hat da viele Möglichkeiten.
Nach wie vor ist doch die einzige 100%ige Möglichkeit für Firmen, einfach so eine Sache nicht in irgendeinem Rechner zu haben, der in irgendeiner Form auch nur annähernd in einem Netzwerk steht.
Ganz richtig.
Und deswegen sollte man es auch gar nicht so oft Internet beschränken. Es handelt sich natürlich auch um andere Netze, also alles, was standardisiert ist und wo es Leute geben kann, die das Wissen sich irgendwie aneignen, wie auch immer, ist natürlich hacken möglich. Und bei manchen Systemen ist das bisher nicht gemacht worden, weil es eben deutlich schwieriger ist für einen Student, sich eine, was weiß ich, 390er von IBM in Kenner zu stellen, als irgendwie einen PC zu kaufen, mit der Unix drauf zu tun. Aber das heißt nicht, dass irgendwelche Großrechner von IBM sicher sind, ganz im Gegenteil. Also was immer wieder gern benutzt wird als Webserver oder irgendwie Datenbanklösungen, sind die AS400-Rechner von IBM zum Beispiel, weil da, wenn man sich da mal bei Sicherheitsproblemen kundig macht, findet man da auch kaum was oder gar nichts. Aber das liegt nicht daran, dass das System jetzt besonders sicher ist, sondern dass einfach wenig darüber bekannt ist. Und ich würde mal ein paar Mark darauf wetten wollen, dass wenn jemand einen Sharecode rausfindet für dieses System, dass wir dann hier plötzlich ein echtes Problem haben, alle Leute, die auf AS400 gesetzt haben. Also es hilft nicht einfach, sich ein obskures System hinzustellen. Und ob man jetzt statt IP, SNA oder sowas spricht, das macht die Sache auch nicht prinzipiell sicherer, sondern man muss eben gucken, dass der Code dagegen geschützt ist, dass man damit Sachen macht, die nicht vorgesehen sind. Und die Sachen sind eigentlich klar, die man machen muss, die werden nur nicht gemacht. Im Grunde kann es auch so halbautomatisch schon mal ein Großteil der Sicherheitsprobleme beseitigt werden.
Vielen Dank.
So, jetzt haben wir eine Menge Abkürzungen gehört, Menge interessanter Geschichten über das Thema Hacking The Internet, Sicherheitslücken. Wenn ihr spezielle Fragen habt oder Geschichten zu erzählen habt oder vielleicht, es gibt sicher auch Leute in Firmen, die jetzt irgendwie ein bisschen nachhaken wollen und sich da ein bisschen weiter informieren wollen oder so, dann könnt ihr das natürlich gerne tun. Und zwar hier, direkt bei uns.
Die Frizz-Hotline ist geschaltet. 0331 für Potsdam 70 97 110.
Sie hört Chaos Radio, Computerplummen bei Fritz, jeden letzten Mittwoch im Monat. Und am Telefon ist zuerst Tino oder Timo. Tino.
So.
Ich wollte mal fragen, wie das ist, so eine großen Firmen, so eine Banken und so was, die haben doch alle, haben die nicht alle ganz schön ein bisschen Angst vor so einen Hackern, dass die da irgendwie ihre Konten oder so auf andere Sachen oder beziehungsweise andere Computer übertragen?
Ja, sehr verständlich haben die Banken da Angst und deswegen kommt unter anderem vor, dass Banken Leute einstellen, die sich damit auskennen und die werden dann eben damit beauftragt, ihre Systeme so zu gestalten, dass das sicher ist. Leider haben Banken da gerade Banken ein echtes Problem, weil die nämlich kompatibel sein müssen zu den Systemen, die die Börsen benutzen und die Bankenaufsicht. Und da gibt es irgendwie 100 Systeme, mit denen man kommunizieren muss und die fahren alle irgendwelche uralt Hard- und Software. Und im Grunde gibt es da auch gar nicht viel Hoffnung, außer dass man eben schön viele Filtersysteme dazwischen setzt und dass man eben jemanden einstellt, der weiß, was er tut. Es hilft einfach nichts.
Wobei gerade bei den Banken ist das halt auch eine Geschichte, dass die das Risiko einfach kalkulieren und da einen gewissen Verlust hinnehmen müssen. Weil die haben natürlich auch von innen von Hackern, die also noch zusätzlich interne Informationen kriegen, eine viel größere Begefährdung als durch das Internet oder die Allgemeinheit, weil die Sicherheitslücken da eben auch eklatant sind und von innen natürlich auch viel besser auszunutzen.
Also die Statistiken gehen davon aus, dass so im Bankenbereich bis zu 80 Prozent der Angriffe von innen kommen, also nicht von außen. Und die wissen schon, dass sie da massive Probleme haben und hoffen eigentlich nur, dass irgendwie niemand auf ihre Hakanen Hardware zurechtkommt. Aber die Hoffnung ist da irgendwie doch ziemlich vergebens, gerade mal die da, die von innen kommen und wissen, was sie tun.
Ich meine, das Spannende an diesen ganzen Geschichten, das war eines meiner frühesten Kindheitserlebnisse. Ich war vielleicht 15, 16 oder so und meine Begeisterung für Computer war natürlich schon da und da habe ich in einem Café gesessen mit einem älteren Menschen, dessen Freundin so hippie war und die hat sich fürchterlich aufgeregt. Die fand Computer einfach so von vorne bis hinten scheiße und hat gesagt, alle Arbeitsplätze kaputt und fürchterlich und keiner wird mehr Arbeit haben, weil alles von Computer gemacht wird. Es ist erstaunlich, dass es nicht mehr Computer überall sind, desto mehr Arbeitsplätze gibt. Das sind natürlich neue. Aber Firmen müssen also, ja weiß ich, hier ist natürlich ein Thema, worüber man ein bisschen länger reden müsste, weil andere Arbeitsplätze zerstört werden. Aber es ist nicht so, dass plötzlich alles automatisch geht, weil irgendwie Sachen müssen sich auch Leute kümmern.
Und außerdem kann man als Bank wunderbar kalkulieren, was jetzt mehr Verlust wahrscheinlich einbringt, weil es leichter zu hacken ist. Ob man jetzt Online-Banking macht oder ob man EC-Karten erlaubt, deren Sicherheit ja auch sehr fragwürdig ist, besonders jetzt, wo ein Desknack durch die Presse gegangen ist.
Also bei den Banken ist halt das große Problem, was die halt wirklich nicht stört, ist nicht, wenn ihr System aufgemacht wird, sondern wo es bekannt wird, dass ihr System aufgemacht wurde. Das ist nämlich viel, viel schlimmer eigentlich für die, weil die halt irgendwie von dem Vertrauen der Kunden leben. Und wenn das halt mal erschüttert ist und die Kunden halt zufällig mitbekommen, dass ihr Geld irgendwie nur so kleine Bits auf den Festplatten dieser Computer, dieser Bank-Sendie, und die Festplatten sind mittlerweile auch schon wieder 20 Jahre alt, dann ist das halt nicht so besonders förderlich fürs Vertrauen der Kunden.
Ja, und dann habe ich noch als nächste Frage, wollte ich mal fragen, was gestern mit dem Kutner los war. Da war ja sowas, bescheuerte Sendung, hat mir also nicht so gefallen.
Sind wir nicht dran schuld, glaube ich.
Nee, glaube ich auch nicht, dass wir da mit irgendwas zu tun haben. Musst du ihn selber anrufen. Dann musst du dir die Passkarte schreiben. Habe ich gar nicht gehört, die Sendung gestern. Ich habe ja meine Autoradio immer mal nicht gehackt, deswegen wahrscheinlich.
Ja, das ist ein ongoing Saga.
Jetzt geht es gar nicht mehr. Wenn man dann irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, 80 mal probiert hat oder so, dann schallt es völlig ab. Da wollte ich jetzt noch was anderes zu sagen, weil das spare ich mir, glaube ich, lieber. Das ist dann vielleicht auch ein bisschen blöd. Du bist ein bisschen unkonzentriert, oder? Nee, ich bin nicht unkonzentriert. Ich finde nur, dass man euch ab und zu mal ein bisschen vergackeiern muss.
Der nimmt uns nicht ernst.
Doch, doch, total.
Schmunzelt. Guck mal, er kann lachen.
Es lacht.
So, Deadlift, hallo.
Ich habe eine Frage zur Sicherheitsabfrage bei seinem heimischen PC. Sprich, ist die Oberfläche von Netscape besser als Internet-Exzora? Gibt es da Möglichkeiten? Das ist wahrscheinlich wieder eine nahe da Frage von jemandem. Und die Frage dazu noch, Linux, ist das dann vielleicht noch sicherer? Schützt das mehr vor irgendwelchen Sicherheitsabfragen? Also von irgendwelchen Daten, die da irgendwie abgefragt werden, Versionsnummern, sonst was alles.
Also die Antwort auf diese Frage lautet, wenn jemand an deinen Rechner rankommt, dann ist dieser Rechner nicht sicher und da kannst du dich ziemlich auf den Kopf stellen.
Nur vom Internet her. Wenn ich also im Internet surfe und jemand ein Programm bei mir dann irgendwie installieren will oder irgendwas.
Du meinst jetzt, was schussfester ist? Also ich habe mit Freebies die gute Erfahrung gemacht. Das läuft auch auf dem Webserver. Und ich kriege immer mit, wie die Windows-User abstürzen. Es gibt da natürlich verschiedene Vorlieben. Da wird auch Hefti gleich gelacht, wenn ich dieses schlimme Wort sage. Also Windows würde ich nicht empfehlen. Felix, sag dir jetzt noch was dazu.
Ja, also ob du eine Netzgeber oder Microsoft Explorer benutzt, ist eigentlich ziemlich wurscht, weil bei dir vielleicht Scheiße sind. Aber Grundvoraussetzung ist erstmal, dass du ein paar Sicherheitssachen grundsätzlich deaktivierst, wie zum Beispiel ActiveX muss auf jeden Fall aus sein. Und das ist eine Sache, die es erstmal nur beim Internet Explorer gibt. Aber wenn du jetzt in der Site gehst und online Banking machst und da deine PIN eingibst, dann sind die beide gleich sicher. Also da brauchst du keine Sorgen, ob dann jetzt Linux oder Windows drauf ist, ist auch egal. Es ist nur so, dass einige theoretische Gefahren bestehen, die halt bei Windows größer sind als bei Linux oder bei FreeBSD oder weiß ich welchen System. Insofern, wenn du Sicherheit haben willst, ist Windows sicher nicht die richtige Wahl. Und wir werden nachher auch noch ein paar Beispielen erläutern, warum Sicherheit nicht nur Leute betrifft, die irgendwo einen Server zu stehen haben, sondern auch den privaten User zu Hause.
Ist klar, ich danke euch nochmal, mach weiter so, ist cool.
Danke.
Ich mache eine Sache noch.
Wie sieht das aus?
Ich war heute mal bei euch im CCC im Internet, das ist ja verschlüsselt. Könnt ihr dazu nochmal was sagen?
Haben wir am Anfang gemacht. Achso, ja dann hör da nochmal rein, da haben wir da einiges dazu gesagt. Deadlip aus Cottbus, das ist eine durchaus berechtigte Frage. Ich glaube, diese Frage stellen sich viele Leute. Ob das irgendwie vom Browser abhängig ist?
Man muss unterscheiden, was für Gefahren einem drohen. Was wir bisher diskutiert haben, sind die Hacker-Attacken auf Server. Gerade den Denial of Service. Das kann natürlich nur ein System betreffen, was in irgendeiner Form Service bietet. Wenn man sich jetzt selber ins Internet einwählt, die Leute, die sich nur mit Modem einwählen, die kriegen jedes Mal eine andere Adresse. Die sind nicht unter einem festen Namen bekannt. Nicht jeder Mensch im Internet versucht sofort, jeden anzugreifen, der sich gerade mal eingewählt hat. Das passiert aber trotzdem. Wenn man in einem Chat sitzt, dann können alle anderen sehen, wer noch alles mit in der Gruppe diskutiert. Nicht selten wird auch gleich der Rechnername bzw. die IP-Adresse von dem Computer eingeblendet. Wenn man die IP-Adresse von einem Rechner hat und aus welchen Gründen auch immer Einfluss auf das System nehmen möchte, dann ist es einfach. Gerade diese ganz normalen Windows-Schüsseln sind im Prinzip offen. In dem Moment, wo ich die IP-Adresse habe, ist es kein Problem, das System innerhalb kürzester Zeit einfach mal zum Stehen zu bringen. Das heißt nicht, dass ich gleich seine ganzen Daten klaue. Also nicht so ein sicheres Problem, sondern dass einfach die Maschine selber zugeballert wird mit Paketen, die das System sofort zum Absturz bringen, weil da eben von Microsoft bestimmte Fehler im TCP-IP-Programm eingebaut wurden bzw. nicht rausgenommen wurden. Und dann steht die Maschine. Also das ist, wenn überhaupt, eine größere Gefahr. Es betrifft vor allem Leute, die halt im Chat sind. Diese Gefahr mit dem Browser ist halt so ein bisschen esoterisch. Also so ein Browser verrät bei jedem Klick sowieso so bestimmte Eigenschaften des Systems, dass zunächst einmal nichts wirklich Gefährliches. Internet Explorer ist da richtig irgendwie interessant. Der erzählt gleich, was man für eine Bildschirmauflösung hat und wie viele Farben und so. Weil könnte man ja vielleicht mal gebrauchen. Und ich bin mir auch sicher, dass die da kräftig sammeln bei Microsoft, was diese Informationen betrifft, um einfach eigene Statistiken zu haben, was die Leute so treiben.
Was wieder für Werbung wichtig ist und so weiter.
Genau. Da können wir auch nochmal dazukommen, dass es sowieso eigentlich nur ums Informationen sammeln geht, um Geld zu verdienen. Aber diese Gefahr, ist mein System jetzt offen mit den Daten, die da drauf sind und können die vielleicht gelöscht werden, das trifft eigentlich erst dann richtig zu, wenn man eben einen Rechner dauerhaft am Netz hat, sprich deinen Server.
Oder wenn man irgendwie anderen Leuten Grund gibt, einen zu ärgern. Also das kommt durchaus vor. In letzter Zeit sind da einige Sachen veröffentlicht worden, wie man eben auch Clients angreifen kann. Und da kommen dann natürlich die gleichen Probleme zur Benutzung, wie wenn man einen Server angreift, nämlich wieder diese Wafferoverflows, die ich vorhin erwähnte. Und gerade Netscape und der Internet Explorer haben sich da gerade wieder vor einigen Tagen sehr negativ hervorgetan, indem man eine Mail verschickt und das bloße Angucken dieser Mail. Oder manchmal muss man sie nicht mal angucken, man muss sie nur geschickt gekriegt haben und dann versucht Netscape, die vom Server zu holen. Und in den meisten Fällen sieht das dann einfach wie ein normaler Absturz aus. Aber wenn jemand dediziert einen Angriff machen wollen würde, könnte er das tun. Und dann könnte er Code auf dem Kleintrechner ausführen und auch dafür sorgen, dass der zum Beispiel spontan bootet oder seine Platte formatiert oder so. Also das ist durchaus möglich, ist aber bisher noch nicht gemacht worden, soweit dokumentiert.
Den einen oder anderen Satz vielleicht noch zum Kleinen Problem. Also zu dem Problem, was wir alle, ihr alle als einfache Internetbenutzer und Server habt, die jetzt nicht unbedingt eine eigene Server betreiben, können wir gleich noch machen.
Wenn Fritz im Raumanger mündet, dann 100, 1.
Es ist 23 Uhr 32 gleich.
Eskalation, die französische Polizei hat ihre Duping-Ermittlungen im Rahmen der Tour de France am Abend noch einmal ausgeweidet. Hotelunterkünfte von insgesamt sechs Mannschaften wurden durchsucht. Der Sportdirektor des französischen Casino Teams wurde festgenommen. Der Fortgang der Tour wird immer ungewisser. Ausweisung, ungeachtet der Kämpfe in der serbischen Unruh, Provinz Kosovo, haben Nordrhein-Westfalen und Niedersachsen heute 93 Jugoslawen nach Belgrad abgeschoben. Darunter befinden sich auch Kosovo-Albaner. Rettungsarbeiten. Eine dramatische Hilfsaktion für die verschütteten Bergleute im österreichischen Lassing ist heute vorerst gescheitert. Ein deutsches Team stieg in das Bergwerk ein, musste aber in einer Tiefe von 100 Metern Ostsicherheitsgründen abbrechen. Die zehn noch verschütteten Männer werden in rund 130 Metern vermutet. Scharfmacherei. Israel setzt in der Jerusalem-Frage weiter auf Konfrontation mit den Palästinensern. Jerosalems Bürgermeister Olmert verteidigte Pläne, wonach mehrere jüdische Besiedlungen in die Stadt eingemeidet werden sollen. Über die Jerusalem-Pläne Israels beraten seit dem Abend die Außenminister aus 16 islamischen Staaten im marokkanischen Casablanca. Freiheitsstrafe. Wegen Kindesmissbrauch muss ein Sexshop-Besitzer aus Wusterhausen für drei Jahre ins Gefängnis. Das Land Wirchen Europin befand den 43-Jährigen für schuldig, Jungen zwischen 12 und 15 Jahren mehrfach sexuell missbraucht und dabei fotografiert zu haben. Wetter. Abends und in der Nacht Schauer 16 bis 14 Grad, morgen gelegentlich Regen bis 25 Grad. Verkehr. Es liegen keine aktuellen Meldungen vor. Fritz wünscht gute Fahrt.
Das war Irina Gabovsky und das ist Fritz Kurz in Form.
Fritz präsentiert eine soft trash Rock'n'Roll Begegnung der dritten Art. Präsentiert von Fritz.
Das Thema heute hier am Chaosradio ist Hacking The Internet. Das haben wir jetzt schon zum zweiten Mal. Ansonsten haben wir uns wenig wiederholt eigentlich in dieser Serie. Hier, die jeden letzten Mittwoch im Monat stattfindet bei Fritz im Gemun. 30.
Ausgabe heute.
Schade eigentlich, dass ich's nicht wusste. Hätte ich schon mal damit gewonnen.
Ja, kannst du das nächste Mal machen.
Ach, machen wir mal bei der 42.
Bei der 33.
Obwohl, einen schönen Vodka. Man sitzt ja hier so weit draus, man muss ja immer noch nach Hause fahren.
Hast du mal davon gehört, dass vor einigen Jahren ein amerikanischer, ein amerikanisches Schiff, ein Zerstörer einen Jumbo-Jet abgeschossen hat? Richtig passiert.
Echt?
Ja, im persischen Golf.
Iranische Maschine, glaube ich sogar noch. Die haben sie mit Zivilisten und so, und waren dann halt alle tot.
Und das tat die dann auch recht leid später?
Genau, und die wurden richtig betrübt.
Was sie dann wirklich noch am meisten betrübt hat, war, dass es dann noch irgendwie Kamerabilder aus der Kommandozentrale gab, wo sie dann auf der Leinwand verfolgen konnten, wie es halt irgendwie so ein Flugzeug da so lang geblippte und ihre Rakete da so lang geblippte, und dann machte das BOOM und sie huelten alle, ja, Treffer. Zu dem Augenblick wussten sie halt noch nicht, dass sie da einen Jumbo abgeschossen hatten.
Und es gab eigentlich nie so richtig eine plausible Erklärung, warum sie da eigentlich irgendwie diesen Jumbo runtergeholt haben. Da hat ihnen dann irgendwie alles ein bisschen leid und so hoppla, kann ja mal vorkommen.
Aber inzwischen wissen wir das.
Dieses Schiff hieß USS Yorktown. Und dann war ein paar Jahre Ruhe und die Yorktown schipperte in aller Seelenruhe durch die Meere. Also, genaueres wissen wir da nicht über die letzten Jahre, aber jetzt haben wir wieder was gehört von der Yorktown, ist wieder was Lustiges passiert.
Ja, also die Yorktown hat jetzt Schlagzeilen gemacht, als sie im Wasser hängen geblieben ist und musste in ihren Hafen geschleppt werden von einem Schlepper.
Also sie war nicht mehr manövrierfähig, also der Störer trieb halt irgendwo rum.
Lag einfach tot im Wasser.
Konnte nicht mehr gesteuert werden, so einfach komplett gar nicht.
Und das ist besonders peinlich, weil die Navy an der Yorktown demonstrieren wollte, wie ihre neue Smart-Ship-Technologie funktioniert. Die einfach zeigen wollte, dass man ein Schiff mit möglichst wenig Personal betreiben kann, indem man Computer einsetzt und eine neue Vorgehensweise der Navy besteht darin, dass man die Betriebskosten runter treiben will, indem man off-the-shelf-Hardware benutzt. Das heißt Sachen, die man so bei Wobe's kaufen kann und nicht irgendwie Spezial-Hardware, die es nur bei, keine Ahnung gibt. Unter anderem fällt natürlich auch Software darunter und da ist der Navy natürlich besonders gedient, wenn die Software irgendwelche tollen Pümpel drauf hat, wo drauf steht, wir sind besonders sicher und noch toller ist, wenn Freiter Staat dieses vergeben hat. Da gibt es seit Jahr und Tag ein Buch, das Sicherheitsrichtlinien festschreibt und Bewertungsmaßstäbe und da gibt es unter anderem die C2-Sicherheit und die ist NT-Version 3.5 oder 3.5.1, was glaube ich vergeben worden und Windows NT und jetzt muss man dazu sagen, dass C2-Sicherheit nicht einem System vergeben wird, sondern einem speziellen Rechner, also genau dieser eine Rechner, das war ein Compact Rechner damals und der hatte weder Netzwerk noch das Kennlaufwerk, hat mit genau dieser eine Version und genau diesen Treibern C2-Sicherheit gekriegt, aber Microsoft macht damit bis heute Werbung und unter anderem hat die Navy aufgrund dieses C2-Stempels sich damals entschieden auf ihre Smart-Chip-Technologie unter anderem als Bestandteil NT zu benutzen und so ist es dann passiert, dass auf der Yorktown ein NT-Rechner nicht richtig programmiert wurde und eine Division durch Null gemacht hat und das System hat das natürlich gemerkt und hat eine Exception ausgelöst und daraufhin hat sich in einer Kennenreaktion die gesamte Yorktown runtergefahren und lag ungefähr Du warst ungefähr zweieinhalb Stunden tot im Wasser und musstest dann in den Hafen geschleppt werden. Und an dieser Stelle sollte man sich vielleicht als Firma fragen, ob es eine weise Entscheidung war, die Datenverarbeitung in der Firma auf Windows 10k aufzustellen.
Das war eine schöne Geschichte. Die Software übrigens gibt es jetzt in der goldenen Reihe für 2019. Sie heißt Build Your Own Schlachtschiff und ist wahrscheinlich neben Buchladen.
Microsoft Ship Builder.
Microsoft Ship Builder, genau.
Microsoft Fleet Commander. Das wird sie es wahrscheinlich eher noch nennen.
2.0.
Diese manische Selbstüberschätzung von Systemadministratoren und Computerberatern in größeren Firmen, die frei nach dem Motto Nobody Ever Got Fired for Choosing IBM in die 90er Jahre einsteigen wollten und das umgedichtet haben in Nobody Ever Got Fired by Choosing Microsoft. Weil was alle machen, das kann ja nichts schlechtes sein. Zumindest sind die anderen genauso doof. Und was sehen wir heute? Alle reden von Windows NT. Man muss da irgendwie Telefonnetze mit aufbauen und am besten auch noch den Web-Server draufpacken. Und dieser Mail-Server braucht man auch noch, weil es gibt ja da alles bei Microsoft fertig. Microsoft Exchange soll ja alles ganz toll austauschen. Vor allem Post, aber das gelingt dem System auch nur begrenzt.
Das ist ein wunderbares Zitat übrigens an der Stelle vielleicht. Und zwar gibt es ja so einen Spruch unter Unix-Hacklern, die sagen, jedes Programm expandiert, bis man damit Mail lesen kann. Und jetzt heißt dieser Spruch außer MS-Exchange.
Am Telefon ist jetzt Carsten erstmal. Hallo Carsten.
Ich habe mal eine Frage.
Und zwar, wie ist es eigentlich Hacker möglich, den Rechner von anderen Internet-Usern zu beeinflussen?
Darum dreht sich eigentlich unsere ganze Sendung. Es gibt da halt verschiedenste Methoden. Gehe einfach davon aus, dass dein Computer eben nicht nur über deine Tastatur und mit deinem Maus Eingaben erfährt, mit denen er dann irgendwas machen muss, sondern jetzt eben, wenn er Internet hat, auch noch Anweisungen aus dem Internet bekommt. In der Regel empfängt er da Daten, die irgendwie sagen, liefer mir mal eine Seite zum Angucken oder übertrag mir mal die und die Datei, wenn du sie hast. Und ein Hacker schaut sich an, wie diese Mechanismen funktionieren und findet dann eben Möglichkeiten, wie man eben dem System auch ganz andere Dinge sagen kann, auf die es vielleicht gar nicht vorbereitet war, also dass der Rechner abstürzt oder überwarte Dinge bereitet.
Also ganz praktisch sieht das so aus, dass der Standardangriff heute auf Leute mit irgendwelchen Windows-Rechnern, die sich im Chat oder sonst wo daneben benehmen, ist einfach, man hat ein Programm und da gibt man irgendwie, startet man dieses Programm, gibt deine IP-Nummer ein und dann schickt er dir einen Satz Pakete auf deine IP-Nummer und dann raucht dein Rechner ab, so. Das ist die Standard-Vorgehensweise zum Wie.
Das was ich von hier aus praktisch hinter dem Pult immer mache, wenn im Chat einer nervt bei Fritz.
Das ist aber kein Hacker, sondern ein Newker.
So was nennt man heute Skript-Kids, weil die einfach nicht wirklich wissen, was sie da tun, aber haben irgendwo ein Programm gefurrt.
Genau, so wie Ecke. Also wenn hier zum dritten Mal jemand in riesengroßen Buchstaben schreiben würde, Amiga ist Gott, dann würde ich hier so ein paar Pakete in seine Richtung schicken und dann...
Rück doch gleich mal die IP-Nummer raus.
Was hat da win los?
Das war's eigentlich schon so weit.
Und jetzt haben wir hier noch Jörg, hallo.
Ja hallo.
Ich habe eine etwas speziellere Frage.
Ich habe bei Trollmoment so ein kleines Netzwerk mit drei Rechnern. Und da wird die CPI-B und NetBiOS über die CPI-B gefahren. Und wir haben jetzt auch ein kleines Internet-Gateway als Software auf Windows 95 Rechner. Und jetzt ist mir natürlich die Frage gestellt, wenn sich jetzt einer da einklickt in meinen Rechner, kann der dann auch über das Netz die Sache von den anderen Leuten lesen?
Ja, aber selbstverständlich.
Das hübsche ist ja, dass ich dann eben auch eine komplette Datei-
und Druckfreigabe habe, weil wir uns ja alle so vertrauen in dem kleinen Netz.
Was musst du übrigens nicht mal tun, um unter Windows irgendwie Daten zu lesen? Windows ist da sehr entgegenkommend, da musst du dich mal von Handweis exportieren, das macht Windows für dich.
Was würdet ihr dagegen vorschlagen?
Na, kein Netzwerkzugang in dem Netz, also nicht irgendwie nach außen. Und wenn jemand in dein Netz reingehen kann, indem er einfach durch die Tür reinkommt, dann ist du sowieso verloren. Also physikalische Sicherheit ist Schritt Nummer eins, um etwas sicher zu machen.
Ist das eine Dauerverbindung oder ist das eine W-Verbindung?
Das ist eine W-Verbindung über ESDN.
Ja, das ist nicht ganz so kritisch.
Also was sehr viel Sinn macht, ist irgendwie dir einen Rechner hinzustellen, der sich nur darum kümmert, einen Router, die wir ja vorhin schon hatten, an dem solche Sachen zusammenlaufen und wo man das einfach ein bisschen überwachen kann. Also wo man irgendwie Werkzeuge hat, mit denen man gucken kann, was läuft da in Richtung Internet und zurück? Und ist die Telefonleitung jetzt aufgebaut oder nicht? So was ist in jedem Fall sinnvoll. Also wenn du dich auf die Sicherheit von Windows verlässt...
Bist du verlassen?
Also wir meinen das ernst. Es ist nicht so, dass wir da immer einen Spaß draus machen, irgendwie auf Microsoft rumzuhacken, weil das ja irgendwie hipp ist für Hacker oder so, sondern man kann es einfach jeden Tag im Internet in 38.000 verschiedenen Nachrichten einfach persönlich überprüfen. Es ist die Katastrophe mit diesem System. Es ist einfach, es liegt offen da, wie ein aufgeschnittenes Pferd, und es ist einfach kein Schutz möglich. Es ist so scheiße programmiert, und alle haben es in der gleichen Binary-Version. Also alle fahren eine identische Kopie, und das ist das größte Problem dabei. Es ist super vorhersagbar, und jeder kann sämtliche Angriffe auf seinem eigenen Rechner zuhause schon mal überprüfen, bevor er auf die anderen losgeht.
Ach so, noch eine Kleinigkeit. Manche Leute glauben, sie machen den Netz sicher, indem sie für diesen eben besprochenen Router NT einsetzen. Das ist natürlich auch falsch. Und das klingt jetzt so, als wenn es sich kleine Leute ausdenken, so mit drei Rechtern. Ich habe das auch schon bei großen Firmen gesehen, so mit International und 100 Wiederlassungen. Also das ist ein Fehler, den ihr nicht tun solltet. Lasst euch auch nicht davon irgendwie einschüchtern, dass es Firmen gibt, die Firewall-Lösungen verkaufen für NT. Wenn NT drunter ist, ist es nicht sicher. Das ist eine kleine Zusammenfassung.
Woran liegt denn das? Also warum ist dieses System so verdammt unsicher? Liegt es daran, dass das Windows von zu Hause aus nie für Netzwerke am Anfang gemacht war? Aber ich meine, NT ist ja wirklich eine andere Geschichte.
Eine der Gründe ist, dass im TCP-IP-Stack von NT sind so Sachen drin. Es waren bis vor wenigen Monaten noch Sachen drin, die bei Unix schon sehr lange gefixt waren. Sie haben offenbar nie sich die Mühe gemacht, also vielleicht haben sie sich das mit 5.0 gemacht, aber bei 4.0 haben sie sich jedenfalls nicht die Mühe gemacht, den kompletten Stack nochmal neu zu schreiben, sondern nach den Fehlern, die da drin sind, sieht es so aus, als hätten sie halt alten Code benutzt.
Haben sie auch bei 5.0 nicht gemacht?
Also es gibt noch einen technischen Grund, warum NT besonders unsicher ist. Das liegt nicht daran, dass das System an sich intern erheblichen Aufwand erfordert, um die einzelnen Subsysteme gegeneinander abzuschotten. Das ist zwar jetzt ein bisschen sehr intern, aber das führt dazu, dass Drittherstellerprodukte normalerweise leichter irgendwelche Sicherheitslücken haben, als wenn das System gleich einen sicheren Übergabestandard zwischen den einzelnen Modulen und Protokollen geben würde. Ich meine, ich brauche jetzt nicht zu sagen, dass das an dem Stack und so weiter blablaliegt. Das führt wahrscheinlich zu weit.
Das heißt, die einzige Alternative für Leute, die ein kleines Netzwerk haben, was vielleicht so eine Standverbindung hat zum Provider oder vielleicht sogar was im nicht selben Provider, heißt immer Unix?
Das macht schon Sinn, weil da gibt es genug Leute, denen macht es Spaß, sich damit auseinanderzusetzen. Und da liegt der Quellcode auch vor. Und gerade fürs Internet eignen sich diese freien Unix ganz hervorragend, weil darauf läuft auch die große Menge des Internets. Und insofern, das ist nicht teuer. Man kann einen billigen PC nehmen. Die sind nicht so hardwarehungrig wie Windows heutzutage. Und da kann man einfach einen der ausgediehnten Rechner zum Geldwellen machen. Und alles ist prima.
Also, um zu sagen, kostet wenig, wir können vielleicht mal Zahlen nennen, damit hier keiner glaubt, wir wollen irgendwas verkaufen. Also in der zweiten Hand werden heute drei 86er verschenkt, weil die einfach keiner mehr haben will. Die kosten 0. Das System darauf kostet auch 0, wenn man sich selber von irgendwo geschafft kopiert. Und wenn man sich eine CD im Laden kauft, kostet das vielleicht 20, 30 Mark. Oder wenn man hochkommt, sagen wir 60 Mark, kauft man auch eine Netzwerkkarte oder nimmt irgendwie eine alte 8-Bit-Karte, weil wenn der irgendwie per Monemann gebunden ist, dann geht er eh nicht mehr als ein paar Byte pro Sekunde rüber. Insofern ist das auch nicht das Bottleneck. Und ein 386SX16 mit irgendwie 4 MB RAM reicht als Gateway. Und das ist auch in Benutzung, auch bei großen Firmen. Und Leute, die sich auskennen, kann man nur sagen, Telefonbewerbung hat Recht, hätte man fragen sollen, der sich auskennt. Und das ist eigentlich... Man kann auch Windows sicher machen, wenn man da richtig viel Aufwand mit greift, aber das macht eben niemand.
Also selbst dann würde ich mir nicht sicher sein, dass es sicher ist. Auch ohne das Haus mit Lizenz würde ich mich da nicht in den Städten sagen, dass man das sicher machen könnte.
Es gibt ein gutes Gefühl, wenn man als jemand, der sowas betreibt, so ein Internetgeld wäre, wenn man da jemanden fragen kann und der kann einem eine Auskunft geben, die auch wirklich Sinn und Verstand hat und nicht irgendwie wie bei Microsoft, da rufst du beim Support an und die verscheißern dich nur oder bei beliebigen anderen kommerziellen Software.
Oder wie sie es auch immer ganz gerne machen, sie schicken sie dann zu uns. Eine Frechheit dieser Laden. Wir haben noch den Jörg dran.
Jörg, bist du schon eingeschlafen?
Nö, ich höre interessiert zu.
Das ist genau das, was ich hören wollte.
Gut, aber es spart dir natürlich auch enorm Kosten, wenn du das einfach nur am Radio tust und nicht direkt über Telefon. Hattest du noch eine andere Frage?
Nee, das war's soweit.
Diese Firewall-Geschichte, die wir jetzt gerade erörtert haben, ist eigentlich auch wieder eins unserer Lieblingsthemen mit dem Unix. Wir reden ja vor allem von freien Unixen, also Linux, FreeBSD, OpenBSD, NetBSD und Verwandte, die, wenn man sie auf einer CD kauft, nicht nur zu installieren sind, wo also nicht so die fertigen Programme drauf sind, sondern wo das System komplett im Source Code kommt, wo man selber als Programmierer halt auch reinschauen könnte. Jemand, der jetzt nur Systemadministrator ist, hat in der Regel nicht die tiefgehenden Unix-Kenntnisse. Das kann man auch nicht erwarten. Und es gibt eine große Hemmschwelle, Unix einzusetzen, weil man immer das Gefühl hat, da müsste man jetzt besonders viel wissen. Das ist auch nicht ganz falsch. Nur ist die Hemmschwelle mittlerweile sehr niedrig. Also so ein Linux-System, das auf eine CD kommt, die Installation gestaltet sich eigentlich problemlos. Und das Wissen sich anzueignen, um eine solche Internetverbindung aufzusetzen und sie dann vielleicht auch noch sicher zu machen, das bedarf zu einer gewissen Einarbeitungszeit, aber die ist zu vertreten. Also sie ist vor allem dem eigentlichen Wunsch, dem man halt angemessen. Wenn man nämlich wirklich ein sicheres System haben will, was auch stabil läuft, dann muss man diesen Aufwand eben treiben und nicht einfach glauben, was in irgendwelchen Vierfaltkatalogen drin steht, mit irgendwie drücken sie hier auf diesen Knopf und alles ist toll. Die Leute wiegen sich in Sicherheit. Die liegen aber offen an einer Wäscheleine rum.
Und wer wirklich glaubt, der kommt überhaupt nicht weiter und braucht dringend Hilfe, der kann auch gern zu unseren Clubtreffen kommen, Club Discordia.
Als Profi der Mann, ne? Da wird gleich ein Kipptreffen mit eingebunden.
Ja, aber so haben wir uns das ja auch gedacht mit dem Donnerstag. Nicht, dass wir da jetzt eine Supportzentrale machen.
Nee, aber es ist halt ein nettes Beisammensein. Es muss ja auch immer nicht sein, dass man dann Hilfe von euch kriegt, sondern es kann auch sein, dass man da andere Leute kennenlernt, die sich um dieselben Themen kümmern. Genau, darum geht es.
Leute, die solche Probleme haben. Ich würde ja gerne das und das tun, aber ich habe das Gefühl, mir fehlt da ein gewisses Grundwissen. Und meistens sind es einfach nur so zwei, drei Hinweise, die man braucht. Das findet man am besten eben in der Diskussion mit anderen Leuten. Und da gibt es einerseits das Internet, wo man zu Linux und Sicherheit und Internet und Firewall alles findet, was man braucht. Aber auch das muss man natürlich erst mal lernen, über das Netz sich solche Informationen anzueignen. Und ansonsten, wir machen halt alle zwei Wochen Club Discordia hier im CCC Berlin. Steht alles auf unserer Website. Morgen ist mal wieder so ein Termin. Und das wäre ein Ort. Oder, wenn ihr weiter weg wohnt, halt andere Treffs, wo Leute sich treffen, die halt irgendwie den kreativen Umgang mit Technologien pflegen.
Vielleicht auch selber Treffs organisieren. Wer ist denn da dran? Keiner mehr.
Ja, eine Frage zu so einer Firewall hätte ich. Da kann man doch irgendwie filtern, dass da alles rausgeht. Wenn man da alles rauslässt, aber nichts reinlässt, dann kommt man dann auch an den Surfer an, oder wird dann sicherer oder nicht sicherer?
Kommt darauf an, an welcher Stelle die Firewall ist. Also wenn die Firewall dich vor deinem Provider schützt, dann ist das schon so, dass du noch hacken kannst. Aber erst mal, Firewalls sind nicht so einfach, dass man genau trennen kann, was rein und rausgehend ist. Weil wenn ich mit dir eine Verbindung aufbaue, sagen wir, um dir Mail zu schicken, dann schicke ich dir ein Paket. Was sagt, ich möchte eine Verbindung aufmachen, und du schickst mir ein Paket zurück, wo drin steht OK. Das heißt, wenn ich einfach gar nichts wieder reinlassen würde, dann würde auch diese Antwort nicht reinkommen. Deswegen Firewalls sind nicht so einfach, wie das klingt, und man kann auch nicht so einfach sagen, was ist jetzt nun rein und was ist rausgehend, was darf ich reinlassen, was nicht. Wenn jetzt aber der Server auf der anderen Seite hinter einer Firewall sitzt, um speziell gegen Hacker zu sichern natürlich, dann wird damit eine gewisse Klasse von Problemen ausgeschlossen, nämlich die unsicheren Dienste, wenn keine Hintertür im Router drin ist. Aber es ist durchaus möglich, dass die Dienste, die noch durchgelassen werden, nach wie vor Probleme beinhalten. Und da gab es auch schöne Beispiele. Zum Beispiel kann man als Webseitenbetreiber eine Search Engine kaufen, die dann die Seiten suchbar macht. Und einer der größeren Anbieter ist Verity in Amerika. Und da gab es jetzt gerade ein Problem, zum Beispiel wo man eben Sachen, sich beliebige Dateien holen konnte, auf dem Website, aber nicht nur die, die halt offiziell exportiert wurden. So eine Sachen können vorkommen, da kann ein Firewall nicht gegen schützen. Deswegen ist ein Firewall nur ein kleiner Teil in einem Gesamtsicherheitskonzept. Und man muss schon auch den Rest der Sachen sich genau angucken.
Also Novell ist so ein richtiger Scheunentorfall. Da ist gerade erst jüngst nochmal dokumentiert worden, dass einfach alle Versionen von Novell, die es bisher gab, ein grundsätzliches Problem haben. Also Novell ist da an keiner Hinsicht sicherer. Das Einzige, was halt etwas sicherer ist, ist, dass ein Novell-Netzwerk normalerweise nicht mit TCP-IP läuft. Also zumindest nicht so wie früher. Jetzt ändert sich das auch langsam. Sondern eben mit einem anderen Protokoll, das heißt IPX, SPX oder jetzt nennen sie es glaube ich NCP. Aber auch dort besteht im Prinzip genau die gleiche Problematik. Auch ein Novell-System bietet, wie das im Internet gemacht wird, den anderen Computer an seine Dienste an. Und in dem Moment, wo er es halt was Sicherheitsrelevantes zu beschützen hat, ist er genauso zugänglich wie der andere Server auch.
Also es gab in Bezug auf Novell auch tatsächlich Berichte von Hacks, wo man irgendwie, machen sie dieses und dann haben sie jenes und solche Geschichten. Das gibt es auch. Es ist halt bei den IP-Protokollen so, dass die besser dokumentiert sind und mehr Leute sich damit auskennen und mehr Leute Code dafür schreiben. Insofern ist die relative Wahrscheinlichkeit, mit einem Novell-Netz gehackt zu werden, nicht so hoch, wie wenn nur irgendwie ein... Es ist einfach pragmatisch gesehen. Natürlich ist es keine Sicherheit, aber es ist halt...
Es gibt genug Hacker-NLMs im Netz, mit denen man so richtig Mist bauen kann. Also dadurch, dass das Novell eine lange Zeit das für ein Netzwerksystem war im kleinen Bereich, gibt es halt eine ganze Menge Novel-Hacks-Geschichten auch. Also da, speziell wenn man im inneren Netzwerk drin ist, dann kann man da wirklich unglaubliche Mengen Mist bauen.
Es gibt hunderte von Anbietern, die Firewalls auf den Markt werfen. Also prinzipiell muss man einfach sagen, wenn die Firma aus Amerika geht, ist es schon mal ein klarer Grund, ihr zu misstrauen, einfach weil wir mal das gleiche wie bei den Routern sind, dass die NSA bestätigen muss, dass da so exportiert werden und wenn nicht, dann müssen wir diesen Code einbauen. Das ist eben ein Problem. Ich glaube, Firewalls kauft man eigentlich nicht, sondern man stellt jemanden ein, der es macht, und lässt sich jemand anderem das nochmal angucken, der sowas auch kann und wenn der auch findet, dass man es so macht, dann ist es gut und ansonsten ist es schlecht. Und wenn man jetzt eine kleine Firma ist, dann muss man eben schauen, dass man im Uni-Umfeld vielleicht jemanden kriegt. Und an der Stelle nochmal ein Appell an Studenten, sorgt dafür, dass an euren Unis nicht NT eingeführt wird, das ist leider ein echter Trend heutzutage, und sorgt einfach dafür, dass Deutschland zurückfällt in die Steinzeit von Leuten, die einfach clicky-bunty und sonst nichts können. Und das ist leider eine Sache. Also momentan ist es gerade so eine Zeit, wo viele Leute von den Unis kommen, die da noch mit Unix in Berührung gekommen sind und die dann zu Hause sich auch mal ein Linux installiert haben oder ein FreeBSD. Und die haben dann auch mal eine Möglichkeit gehabt, was zu lernen, aber mit NT ist die Möglichkeit eben einfach nicht gegeben, es sei denn, man gibt richtig viel Geld für dieses Developerzeug aus. Und Firewalls, die irgendwelche Leute zusammengeschraubt haben, kann man im Grunde erst mal nicht trauen, es sei denn, man kennt sich damit genug aus, um es zu beurteilen. Und das können eben nicht wirklich viele Leute. Da muss man eben mindestens zwei Leute sich das angesehen haben und die sagen dann eben, ist gut so oder ist nicht gut. Und wer man auch auf keinen Fall trauen sollte, sind irgendwelche Zeitungen, die sich so einen Test machen. Da gibt es in Amerika einige, die das tun. Die haben sich dann eben ein paar Produkte kommen lassen und haben halt geguckt, ob das Interface intuitiv ist und haben vielleicht irgendwie Zweitele Hex ausprobiert, die im Internet rumlagen. Also es ist nicht so, dass die Redakteure da Ahnung haben von, weil wenn sie Ahnung hätten, würden sie selbst Firewalls verkaufen. Damit kann man deutlich mehr Geld achten, als mit Berichten darüber schreiben.
Und noch eine andere Frage, also ich kenne es bis zu uns von der Arbeit.
Du musst mal deine Radio lasermachen, glaube ich.
Die Sendung ist an Ihrem ersten Mittwoch im Monat.
Wie heißt das?
Wenn man auf Arbeit im Internet ist und dann irgendeine Anfrage zu einem Surfer geschickt wird.
Da ist eine Radio nicht ausgemacht.
Der schickt dann immer wieder Pakete zurück, obwohl man dann abgebrochen hat. Das geht dann immer hinweg tagelang oder stundenlang. Manchmal sind es auch tagelang gegangen. Kann man das als Firma auch irgendwie abbrechen?
Dafür ist eigentlich Firewalls da, dass man eben erkennt, dieses Paket ist jetzt keine Antwort auf eine Verbindung, die ich aufgebaut habe als Client. Also ist das irgendwas, was ich nicht erlauben will. Und dann werden die eben weggeschmissen.
Da wird nichts passieren. Der ganze Rechner stellt da immer Anfragen. Nehmt mit, dass unser Rechner da gesagt hat, ne ich will nicht. Das kriegt der andere Rechner nicht mit.
Das kannst du nicht verhindern. Das ist natürlich dann insbesondere sehr lästig, wenn die Verbindung eine Wehleitung ist und aus dem Internet auch aufgebaut werden kann. Das kann zu erheblichen Telefunkosten führen. Da habe ich schon einschlägige Erfahrungen. Aber da kannst du prinzipiell nichts gegen machen. Das heißt, wenn du einen Internetzugang hast und das Internet auch sozusagen die aktive Seite darstellt, dann musst du damit leben, dass dir Mist geschickt wird. Also meine Philosophie ist, Sachen, die ich nicht haben will, einfach zu ignorieren und auch gar nichts zurückzuschicken. Das bewehrt sich, weil das auch nicht besonders einladend ist, da mehr Sachen auszuprobieren, wenn das Zeug alles in Müll handelt.
Übrigens an der Stelle ist auch ein gutes Kriterium zu erkennen, ob der Provider fit ist oder nicht. Denn man kann durchaus mit seinem Internetprovider reden, dass der schon ein bisschen fehlt hat und dann wird die Telefonleitung entlastet und Verbindungen werden nicht aufgebaut, wenn sie unnötig sind.
Genau, so hat es dann auch unser Ex-Tabler, der alles mit Internet macht, der hat dann zum Provider gesagt, dass er da die IP-Adresse stammt, dass da nichts mehr kommt.
Na ja, das ist unbedingt eine tolle Idee, weil das kann durchaus eine W-Leitung von Telekom sein, wo halt jedes Mal jemand anders hintersteckt und einmal hat einer seine Hardware nicht im Griff gehabt. Also das ist durchaus häufig. Normalerweise gibt es so einen schönen Spruch unter Sicherheitsleuten, dass man nie was mit bösem Willen erklären soll, was man auch mit Dummheit erklären kann. Also in allergrößten Anzahl der Fälle kommen Pakete, die eben auffallen, nicht dadurch, dass irgendjemand Mist macht, weil er eben böse sein will, sondern es sind irgendwelche Leute, die ihre Software nicht im Griff haben. Ein gutes Beispiel dafür ist zum Beispiel wieder NT, denn wenn man vor allem einen NT-Server benutzt, um zu surfen, was durchaus Leute machen, dann stellt der auch mal nicht nur Anfragen bei Port 80, das ist der Standard HTTP-Port, sondern der meldet sich auch mal auf Port 137, das wird von NT intern als Nameservice-Ersatz benutzt. Und sowas fällt dann auch mal bei der Firewall auf, und das machen die nicht, um dich zu ärgern, sondern das macht eben die Software, weil sie scheiße ist. Und deswegen die IP zu sperren, das hilft vielleicht so ein bisschen, dass die Logs eben nicht mehr meckern, weil da drin steht, der hat versucht zu hacken, aber es hilft das Problem nicht wirklich, und solange die Leute bei dir nichts Böses tun, muss ich da einfach ignorieren und fertig.
Was hören wir denn jetzt hier?
Ich weiß nicht.
Nein, jetzt hören wir gar nichts mehr. Da war dann irgendwas auf dieser DAT-Kassette hinten drauf. Marco, haben wir damit ein paar Fragen beantwortet?
Ja, alles klar.
Jutti, dann haut dir einen schönen Abend.
Ja, ich bin Manfred. Ja, und zwar, du hast es eben kurz erwähnt, wenn man E-Mails bekommt, dann gibt es auch schon die Möglichkeit, dass da jemand zugefasst auf dem Rechner, nur wenn man sie noch nicht mal liest.
Wir wollen uns Microsoft nicht übertreiben.
Nein, das kommt auch bei anderen vor.
Da handelt es sich im Normalfall aber nicht um den tatsächlichen Inhalt der Mail, dass man ja so irgendeinen Brief schreibt und bevor du den schon aufgemacht hast, ist da was passiert, sondern normalerweise eben um das Ausnutzen von Protokollfehlen oder von fehlerhaften Protokollimplementationen in den zwischenliegenden Systemen, die deine Mail dann irgendwie weiterverarbeiten. Also es gibt immer wieder diese Mail irgendwie, Achtung, Good Times, diese Mail nicht lesen, sonst wird die Platte gelöscht und so. Das ist eigentlich immer Quatsch. Also es gibt zwar Möglichkeiten, aber die sind meistens komplexer und man sollte sich da nicht zu leichthaltig anzuhören lassen.
Also es gab schon Mails, mit denen man tatsächlich die Platte formatiert hat. Und zwar gab es bei einem dieser, ich kenne diese ganzen Mail-Räder von Microsoft nicht, da gab es einen, der unter bestimmten Bedingungen URLs automatisch interpretiert hat. Da gab es auch Text, wenn man dann den Inter Explorer benutzt hat, von einer bestimmten Version, mit der man Aboriginal Commands auf der Platte ausführen konnte.
Und das ist ja bei Windows 98 alles glücklicherweise eingebaut, der Virus ist mitgeliefert sozusagen.
Genau, da gab es tatsächlich eine Situation, wo man mit einer Mail, die auf eine URL umlegte, deine Platte formatiert hat.
Aber das mit den Good Times ist halt nicht mehr so.
Das ist unsinn, ja. Aber man muss mal Folgendes sagen, glücklicherweise sind die Software-Layer so kompliziert, dass normalerweise so eine tödlichen Mail gar nicht erst beim User ankommt, sondern auf den Weg kräft schon mal der Exchange-Server. Und der ist bekannt dafür, zum Beispiel die Version 5.0, die eigentlich klingt wie eine richtig fortschrittliche, moderne Version.
Also redest von Microsoft Exchange, die Mail.
Genau, Microsoft Exchange, richtig.
Das Teil, was Microsoft erstaunlicherweise selber benutzt. Jedenfalls, Version 5.0 stößt beim ersten Kommando ab, was man ihm geben kann, wenn man da sich als zu langer Rechnername out und meldet. Dann sagt Exchange erstmal Absturz und Version 5.5, die jetzt vertrieben wird. Da ist genau derselbe Fehler an einer klitzekleinen anderen Stelle. Das ist ein bisschen anderes Kommando, was man dem Web-Server gibt. Nämlich da, wo man sagt, ich bin User so und so. Beim New-Server braucht der Exchange wieder ab. Es gibt keinen Grund, dem Rest von Exchange zu trauen. Auf dem Weg von einer solchen Mail zum Client ist auch noch ein iMap-Demon oder ein POP-Server auf dem Weg. Der kann genauso abstürzen, wenn da Stimmebefehle drin sind. Außerdem ist ein Angriff zu machen, richtig komplex, weil man genau wissen muss, welche Software-Versionen, auf welcher Betriebssystem-Version die Mail lesen wird. Das ist ja auch erstmal nicht so einfach, wenn man nicht gerade NetScape oder Outlook Express benutzt, die das nämlich in die Mails immer reinschreiben.
Wie ist das bei NetScape?
Bei NetScape kann man also das ActiveX nicht...
Dann wollte ich mal fragen, was für ein Sicherheitslücken, wenn man noch mit Windows 3.11 arbeitet, Vergleiche zu Windows 95?
Ich kenne da zum Beispiel einen sehr berühmten Mailclient Eudover, da gibt es eine Windows 3.11 Version, die hatte schon damals irgendwelche Overrun-Probleme bei bestimmten etwas komisch formatierten Mailheadern. Also die Clients creschen auch unter Windows 3.11, aber der Großteil der Client Exploits wird halt für Windows 95 gemacht.
Aber das heißt nicht, dass Windows 3.11 sicher ist, das ist wieder diese Sicherheit durch unklare Sachen, Sicherheit durch Obscurity wird es genannt. Also die Liste der Mailclients, von denen jetzt vor kürzester Zeit dokumentiert wurde, dass sie solche Probleme haben mit den Malm-Mails, sind unter anderem Outlook, Outlook Express, Netscape, Eudover, und zwar der Unix-Programm und auch Metamel, das ist uralt. Also sowas kommt vor, sowas kommt natürlich Netscape auf allen Plattformen, ganz klare Sache, und deswegen sollte man sich die Mailprogramme in Ruhe ansehen, die man benutzt, und das heißt nicht, dass etwas sicher ist, weil es neu ist. Das ist eine Sache, die immer wieder gerne geglaubt wird, wenn man jetzt eine neuere Novellversion benutzt, dass sie dann sicherer ist zum Beispiel. Das heißt nur, dass sie andere Bugs eingebaut haben.
Ich hatte schon mal unter Windows 95, also mein Mailprogramm, also ich bin bei CompuSurf und das war sehr schwierig zu installieren, und einmal ist der Rechner abgestürzt, als ich online war, und dann nachher bin ich nicht mehr reingekommen.
Das heißt nicht unbedingt, dass jemand eine Attacke versucht hat?
Aber das System ist ja instabil, und das Deinstallieren und Neuen installieren ist so aufwendig, deswegen bin ich wieder zurück auf Windows 3.11, und da läuft das alles prima, mit dem Mailprogramm und auch im Internet.
Was sollen wir da noch zu sagen? Wir sagen es einfach die ganze Zeit, diese ganze Windows-Mumme, egal welche Zahl dahinter steht, das ist alles die gleiche Qualitätsklasse.
Eine andere Frage noch, den Browser Opera, habt ihr damit Erfahrungen?
Der läuft auf meinem 486 SX25, und da werden wir uns schneller als mein Netscape auf einem 100 MHz Powerup jetzt sehen.
Deutlich schneller.
Das ist schon irgendwie ein cooler Browser, und zum Glück sind die Jungs gerade dabei, auch alle möglichen anderen Plattformen zu portieren, nicht nur Windows, und dass ich kenne viele Leute, die mit dem Browser sehr zufrieden sind, gerade was die Geschwindigkeit betrifft.
Das heißt aber nicht, dass es nicht sicher als Fehler hat. Es ist sehr viel schlanker als Netscape und Internet Explorer, und gerade diese aufgeblasenheit der Programme, die bringt die meisten Probleme mit sich, weil die Programmierer einfach selber gar nicht mehr schneiden, die komplexe Systeme geworden ist und die Auswirkungen von einer Sache nicht auf die andere anwenden können. Das heißt aber nicht, dass es mit Opera anders ist.
Hier kam noch mal die Frage, wie denn solche Exploits in Clients genau aussehen. Also es gibt in den aktuellen Programmen, die du genannt hast. Felix, magst du dazu was sagen? Du kannst, gut dann erkläre ich das, man kann im Prinzip eine Mail so formatieren, dass diese erwähnten Programmstücke, die man auch über das Netz einspielen kann, auch enthalten und beliebige Sachen in dem Computer anstellen, wenn es sich um einen Windows-Computer oder Macintosh oder irgendeinen anderen Computer mit einem wohlbekannten Binärinterface handelt, dann kann man halt beliebige Sachen machen. Man ist natürlich dann ganz besonders gekniffen, wenn das Betriebssystem keinerlei Sicherheitsmechanismen beinhaltet und man als normaler Surfer sozusagen auch das System komplett umkrempeln kann. Da ist Windows 95 oder 98 natürlich ganz besonders wichtig.
Also eins können wir dir mit auf den Weg geben, diese Sicherheitsprobleme, das ist so ein superschwammiges Wort, das unglaublich viele Dinge umfasst. Die gibt es im Internet und sind im Wesentlichen ein Problem der Server. Endanwender sind jetzt nicht automatisch gefährdet. Umso mehr du dich dem Netz anvertraust, umso mehr du Bankgeschäfte machst oder so über das Netz, umso mehr musst du darüber natürlich auch nachdenken. Dann ist dein Bedenken auch genau am richtigen Platz. Worauf wir vor allem hinauswollen, ist, dass alle Leute jetzt Internet machen und immer mehr Firmen und offizielle Stellen ihre Systeme computerisieren. Siehe dieses Beispiel mit diesem Zerstörerschiff, dass die sich eben auf sehr wackeliges Terrain begeben.
Ich würde keine Entwarnung geben, was den einzelnen Internetbenutzer angeht, dass der nicht gefährdet sei, weil diese Client Exploits eben dazu benutzt werden können, private Informationen auf der Platte nach draußen zu reichen, ins Netz zu reichen. Ich meine, die Technologie ist mit diesem BTX-Hack da, der neulich gelaufen ist, halt vorgestellt worden. Und durch solche Sicherheitslücken, wie sie in den Clients jede Menge vorhanden sind, ist es eben genauso denkbar, dass man Kontostände, Daten, was auch immer, mit einer speziell formatierten Mail aus dem Computer rauslutscht und mit der nächsten Mail auch ins Internet wieder abschickt, ohne dass der Benutzer da irgendeine Chance hat, mit Sucht um was er gelaufen ist.
Ist es da ein Unterschied, wenn man bei CompuServe ist oder bei Germanynetz? Ist man da nicht sicher, wenn man so solche Probleme hat?
Leider, im Gegenteil, kann er sein, dass er vorweilig auch mit abbraucht, wenn er richtig schlecht ist auf der Einsatz.
Okay, Manfred, erstmal beantworten zu weit.
Noch eine Kleinigkeit zur Yorktown. Es ist nicht unbedingt so, dass die Navy weiß, was sie tut. Denn unter anderem haben sie herausgegeben, was sie tun werden, um solche Probleme in Zukunft zu beheben. Und unter anderem stand darin, dass es passiert, weil ein User eine Null eingegeben hat. Und das System hat dann gewarnt und er hat gesagt, er will aber eine Null haben. Und jetzt haben die Navy also herausgegeben, wenn sowas passiert, dann soll man da lieber eine Einschreibung schreiben und lieber Müll eintragen und dann wird es schon alles gut werden. Und daraus sieht man, das ist nicht unbedingt ein Softwareproblem, sondern es ist auch meistens ein, weil die Leute überhaupt keine Ahnung haben, was sie da tun. Und wenn man sich überlegt, dass so ein Kriegsschiff vielleicht hier irgendwie vor Hamburg kreuzt, dann möchte man doch irgendwie...
Also es ist ein Gehirnproblem.
Richtig, das ist ein spezielles Problem.
Richtig. Also was noch ganz lustig ist, dass ein Zyniker im Netz dazu meinte, wenn alle Leute Windows benutzen würden, hätten wir keine Kriege mehr, weil die Waffen einfach nicht mehr funktionieren. Das ist doch ein ruhender Gedanke.
Du meinst, Microsoft ist eigentlich auf der Suche nach dem Weltfrieden.
Genau, Microsoft will uns alles nur was binden.
Da hat schon wieder jemand aufgegeben. Hallo, wer ist denn da?
Ja, hier ist der Dominik. Ich wollte ja nochmal fragen, wenn ich mir jetzt einen neuen Computer kaufe, wie ist denn das denn, kann ich den Klee nach Hacker schützen irgendwie, wenn er völlig neu ist?
Na ja, normalerweise installiert man sich die Probleme erst. Also ich meine, es ist schon so, dass die Systeme so im mitgelieferten Umfang einfach ein schlechtes Topf dabei haben. Aber so richtig krass ist es eben erst jetzt mit Windows 98 geworden, wo so Sicherheitsbomben wie der Internet Explorer einfach im Lieferumfang sind. Es ist schon mal viel geholfen, wenn man den ganzen Mist, den man nicht braucht, oder wo man nicht weiß, was es tut, einfach nicht mit installieren. Und die Services, einfach wenn man gefragt wird, soll dieses oder jenes laufen, so nicht sagen, na ich könnte es vielleicht mal brauchen, hier installiert es jetzt mal, sondern einfach alles abschalten, was man nicht kennt. Und dann wenn es eine Fehlermeldung gibt, dann kann man immer noch nachinstallieren.
Ein guter Tipp ist auch, die Platte nicht so zu nehmen, wie sie vom Händler kommt, sondern sich den Krämpel selbst zu installieren, weil das auch darauf vorbereitet, dass der Mist mal irgendwie kaputt gehen kann, dass die Platte kaputt gehen kann, und dass man dazu gezwungen ist, von vorne an zu fangen.
Das machen wir so nachzudenken.
Ja, das habe ich sowieso gehört mit dem Windows 98. Das soll auch sowieso nicht so gut sein, wenn ich mir jetzt an die Vorführung denke, dass es darum abgestürzt ist oder so.
Macht ihr eine Partition auf die Platte, da machst du dein Windows drauf. Und wenn du irgendwie Linux ausprobieren willst, machst du noch eine Partition. Die Platten sind heute so groß, dass es eigentlich ziemlich egal sein kann. Und einfach so ein bisschen sich darauf vorbereiten, dass man was anderes ausprobiert.
Lernen, lernen, lernen.
Ja, gegen Sicherheit hilft nicht, dass man jemanden holt oder ein Buch liest und dann einfach auch die Tagliste abarbeitet, sondern gegen Sicherheitsprobleme hilft, dass man verstanden hat, was das Problem ist.
Das hilft gar nicht, dass man sich von Microsoft die neueste Software kauft.
Die müssen sie ja inzwischen verschenken, damit sie Leute nehmen. Und sogar du.
Kann ich mir also noch eine andere Frage, wie ist das, wenn ich mir jetzt im Internet, wenn ich jetzt im Internet irgendwie downloade, kann ich da irgendwie gegen Viren schützen?
Jetzt machen wir was ganz anderes.
Handelsüblich. Kannste kaufen oder kopieren.
Oder laden.
Ne, aber bevor ich überhaupt downloade.
Na, vor dem Downloaden kennst du die Daten nicht. Kannst also nicht wissen, ob da ein Virus drin ist oder nicht.
Also viele FDPs machen halt einen Virencheck, wenn sie es können. Aber mittlerweile haben einige dafür auch schon deutlich aufgegeben.
Na, wie viele Viren gibt es inzwischen dokumentiert? Irgendwie 15.000 oder so?
Es soll ja diesen neuen Virus jetzt geben, diesen C-I-H-Virus, der jetzt irgendwie...
Es gibt einfach alle 20 Minuten einen neuen Virus, eine neue Server-Attacke, ein Problem mit einem Programm, das kommt nicht alle 5 Tage oder alle 2 Wochen. Das ist einfach permanent. So wie es hier Verkehrsunfälle gibt. So gibt es irgendwie Probleme mit Computern. Und so viele Leute wie auf Deutschland Straßen sterben, so viele sterben auch irgendwie jeden Tag. Irgendwie Systeme brechen Datenbanken weg, werden Platten geputzt von Firmen, die dann auf einmal vor der großen Katastrophe stehen, weil einfach die Arbeit von 8 Monaten gelöscht ist.
Ja, FDP war doch hier gerade so ein schönes Beispiel. FDP-Webserver ist irgendwie an einem Tag 2-mal gehängt worden. Das ist schon echt mega peinlich so was.
Hat das deine Frage erstmal so weit beantwortet? Schönen Abend. Ja, Dankeschön. Ist er überhaupt nicht abgestürzt und nicht gehackt worden? Ich habe ihn ausgeschaltet. Es gibt verschiedene Versionen von diesem Chat hier im WWW. Es gibt eine sehr schöne Version, die zumindest für den Administrator sehr klasse ist, weil da alles geht, also Kicken und bla, sehr IRC-mäßig.
Es gibt eine God-Function.
Es gibt eine God-Function, genau. Der ist allerdings vom Interface nicht so nett, finde ich. Die weiß ich nicht, Zeilenabstand ist zu groß und so. Und der andere, da kann ich nicht einzeln kicken. Und weil mir sämtliche Amiga-User so dermaßen auf den Wecker gegangen sind und echt genervt haben, habe ich den Chat abgeschaltet. Bedankt euch also bei denen, die irgendwie...
Im Classic-Chat gibt es eine Ignore-Funktion. Da kannst du einfach einfach entscheiden, du musst keinen Amiga lesen.
Nee, in der anderen Version geht das ganz wunderbar. Da kannst du dann auch die Leute einzeln rausschmeißen und so. Vor allem finde ich es eigentlich völlig blöd, also das ist wie in so einem Gespräch. Man schmeißt ja nicht jemanden raus, aber wenn irgendwie diese ganze Fenster vollgeschrieben wird mit irgendwelchen bekloppten Amigasprüchen, das ist das beste Beispiel, warum man für dieses System so garantiert keine Werbung macht. Es ist immer so, wenn Amiga-User im Chat sind, sind immer die letzten Volldeppen.
Das kann man so unistellig machen.
Durchschnittsalter 8 Jahre und es ist aber so.
Inzwischen sind die alle zu viel online gegräbt.
Das hat einfach was damit zu tun, wie lange man sich mit Computern beschäftigt. Und Minderheiten haben immer das Problem, dass sie laut werden möchten. Hier kommt doch uns an, die letzten drei Jahre mit Macintosh.
Ja, aber ich gehe doch nicht in den Chat und schreibe dann 800 Mal Macintosh da rein.
Wir erzählen jedem irgendwie die Kante voll.
Aber du kannst auf Mac nicht automatisieren, vielleicht?
Ich glaube der Amiga hat so eine Taste, wo er dann immer so...
Johnny ist genervt. Amiga, Jungs, lass es sein.
Ach, lasst mich in Ruhe mit eurem Spielzeugcomputer.
Ihr kriegt sogar eine E-Mail.
Ich habe ja auch so eine hübsche Filterfunktion, wenn der jetzt steht. Aber Amiga, Jule, alle ganz toll, wenn man die gleich rausgefiltert.
Oh, Johnny, man, tust uns leid.
Nee, ich will nur ein bisschen stecken.
Was benutzt du auf Webchats? Wir haben hier einen schönen ASCII-Chat auf www.ccc.de.
Chat ist sowieso totaler Quatsch. Das ist echt CB-Funker-Mentalität, finde ich.
Übrigens, da gab es auch zwei schöne Exploits, die ich an der Stelle vielleicht erwähnen kann. Und zwar für ICQ und den AOL Instant Messenger, der leider bei dem englischen Netscape gleich mit installiert wird, ohne dass man ihn irgendwie...
Als ICQ solltest du vielleicht nochmal erzählen, was das ist.
Den kannst du aber auch nicht mit installieren. Zumindest unter Mac kannst du den abschalten.
Ja, unter Windows nicht. Nein, also das ist wieder das Problem, dass Leute sich ihr Protokoll selbst definiert haben und haben dann wieder Leute eingestellt, die gesagt haben, wir sind morgen fertig, und nicht Leute, wie gesagt, haben, die brauchen eine Woche, aber dafür ist gut am Ende. Und so eine Software kommt eben daraus. Und bei SEQ gibt es zum Beispiel einige Probleme mit der Authentifizierung von Clients. Das heißt, man kann einfach von einer beliebigen IP-Adresse sagen, man ist jemand anders. Und so haben die Leute sich gegenseitig ihre Mail gelesen und Mail geforscht und sonst was gemacht. Und bei MarlOL Instant Messenger gab es wieder ein Buffer-Overflow. Das heißt, wenn man da irgendwie eine Nachricht abgegeben hat, da konnte man ein beliebigen Code ausführen. Und so eine Sache wird immer wieder passieren. Und man muss einfach sagen, Windows ist gar nicht mal unbedingt deswegen so scheiße, weil das System so schlecht ist, sondern weil die Leute einfach nicht programmieren können. Und alle Neuprogrammierer werden heutzutage nicht gesagt, hier, wir schließen dich im Raum ein und du kommst raus, wenn du ein gutes Programm geschrieben hast, sondern denen wird Visual Basic in die Hand gedrückt und dann kommt da einfach Schrott bei raus. Und das ist ja auch von vornherein, kann man ja abzählen, das ist ja auch allen klar, das ist ja auch die Idee hinter Visual Basic, dass Leute, die keine Ahnung an Programme machen können. Aber es ist eben nicht so, dass man sich dann am Ende irgendwie rechtmäßig wundern darf, wenn die Programme alle scheiße sind.
Aber du kannst ja jetzt auch mit dem Swatch-Auto, kannst du ja jetzt auch selber Autos zusammen basteln, oder wird das wahrscheinlich dann ein ähnliches System sein, in dem du weißt, was damit alles passiert?
Enttämmersiert.
Nein, das ist natürlich eine ganz andere Geschichte. Aber da ist natürlich wahrscheinlich ein klassischer Voll von so großer Nachfrage und zu wenig Leute, die das einfach können. Wahrscheinlich muss man die deswegen so schnell treten. Ich meine, wie lange, also wenn du immer sagst, die haben keine Ahnung, die haben keine Ahnung, was denkst du denn, wie lange ein Programmierer, der Ahnung hat nach deinem Maßstab, nach deinem Sicherheitsmaßstab, wie lange muss der geschult sein?
Zehn Jahre.
Ach, das kann man erstmal so nicht sagen, weil Ahnung ist immer auf kleine Bereiche gemacht.
Aber Ahnung ist ja einfach Erfahrung zum Beispiel. Das sieht man ja im Web genauso. Also, wie viele Leute sagen, ich kann eine Seite basteln, kann jeder.
Ja, was das Problem ist, man kriegt nur Ahnung, wenn man das auch wirklich tatsächlich lernt. Und das lernt man halt on the job. Und dabei kommt richtig viel Mist bei raus.
Also das Problem ist einfach, wenn ich dir zeige, ich schicke dir diese Mail und dann stürzt dein Netzcap ab, dann hast du gelernt, irgendwie meinen System stürzt ab, wenn ich eine Mail kriege. Aber du hast nicht gelernt, was das Problem dabei ist. Das heißt, im Grunde lernt man Sicherheit, wenn man selber was geschrieben hat, was unsicher ist, und jemand zeigt einem das und dann versucht man es zu verstehen. Und versteht es auch. Und deswegen würde ich jedem empfehlen, zum Beispiel mal, wer unter Unix was programmiert, einen Fingerdienel zu installieren. Einfach selber schreiben, das ist ein echt trivialer Dienst. Der kriegt einfach einen Usernamen gesagt und soll Informationen zurückheben. Und so einen Dienst schreibt man mal und dann lässt man sich von jemandem, der kompetent ist, zeigen, warum das schlecht ist, wenn man da irgendwie einen 1000 Zeichen langen Usernamen eingibt und man hat nur 500 vorgesehen. Und wenn man das verstanden hat, dann hat man im Grunde verstanden, wie man Programme sicher machen kann. Das ist nicht wirklich schwierig. Aber es ist eben so, dass viele Leute gar nicht daran interessiert sind, das wirklich zu lernen, sondern die möchten eben Geld verdienen und lassen sich dann von Microsoft-Netzwerk-Zertifikat geben und glauben, sie sind jetzt tolle Programmierer. Das ist einfach das Problem, dass heute in der Branche nicht gefragt wird, wie willst du mir denn jetzt beweisen, dass du Ahnung hast, sondern es wird gefragt, zeig doch mal dein Zertifikat oder dein Uni-Abschluss. Und an der Uni wird dir eben nicht gesagt, also wenn du irgendwie diesen Fehler machst, dann kann jemand mit deinem Programm auf dem Rechner Daten klauen, sondern dir wird eben gesagt, benutze irgendwie diese Methode für die formale Verifikation, die irgendwie dreimal so lange braucht, wie das Programm zu schreiben, das macht also nie jemand. Und solange nicht dem User gezeigt wird, wenn er dann mal anfängt zu programmieren, was das Problem eigentlich ist, viele verstehen das Problem gar nicht. Das sieht man auch bei Microsoft ganz gut übrigens, weil da immer wieder Patches rauskommen für Sicherheitsprobleme, die das Problem überhaupt nicht verstanden und behoben haben, sondern eben genau diesen eindokumentierten Angriff, den dieses eine Programm macht, das einmal publiziert wurde, herausfiltern. Und wenn man das leicht modifiziert, dann fällt das gleiche Programm wieder auf die Nase. Also vorhin habe ich an Exchange gesagt, das war genau das Problem. Die Leute, die das gefixt haben, haben offenbar überhaupt nicht verstanden, was das Problem ist, sondern sind bei dem nächsten Befehl wieder auf die Nase gefallen, wenn man da zu lange Namen angibt. Und das ist einfach das Problem, dass man Leute programmieren lassen muss, die das Problem verstanden haben. Und es ist natürlich schwierig für einen Manager zu erkennen, ob der, den man jetzt einstellen möchte, weiß, was er tut oder nicht. Aber die Aufgabe kann einfach jemand, der es nicht drauf hat, nicht erledigen. Das ist einfach ein Problem.
Was machst du beruflich?
Ich?
Und hat er Ahnung?
Du sag doch mal.
Der weiß schon, wovon er spricht.
Wenn ich mal ein Sicherheitsproblem habe, weiß ich, wer ich anrufe. Wer ist denn da? Hallo? Wie heißt du?
Ja, in zwar hatte ich mal eine Frage, weil da ihr ja sagt, Netzcape und Internet ist sowieso scheiße, was infiziert ihr denn als Internet?
Na, wir benutzen auch Netzcape, aber wir wissen halt, dass es scheiße ist.
Also gibt es keine weiteren Alternativen?
Doch, klar.
Na, du kannst mal Opera probieren und die hinläuflich mit Netzcap bekannten Probleme an Opera ausprobieren. Und wenn du da weniger Probleme mit hast, dann benutze Opera. Ach, die haben beide schon ziemlich die gleichen Probleme. Das ist ja auch etwas, was einen echt erstaunen muss, weil die Probleme bei Netzcape sind ja teilweise publiziert worden, bevor Internet Explorer überhaupt gegeben hat. Und als es ihnen dann gab, hat der genau die Probleme wieder gehabt. Also es ist nicht so, dass die irgendwie da völlig disjunkt werden. Also dass irgendwie einer ein Problem hat, das der andere nicht hat. Also es kommt ab und zu mal vor, wie Internet Explorer eben ActiveX mitliefert. Und das ist einfach inhärent scheiße und unsicher. Und da kommen natürlich irgendwie gleich eine ganze Klasse von neuen Problemen. Aber es ist nicht so, dass man sagen kann, der eine ist sicherer als der andere.
Also was war jetzt mit dieser Java-VM? Es gibt irgendwie in einem der Browser, war das NetzCAP?
Ja, bei NetzCAP gab es gerade wieder so ein Problem. Das ist eine Kombination aus drei Bugs. Es ist ja auch nicht so, dass ein Bug ungefähr dafür sorgt, dass das Programm gleich irgendwie benutzt werden kann, um Daten zu klauen. Aber es gab jetzt drei Bugs, die alle für sich allein nicht so schlimm sind, aber die zusammengenommen benutzt werden können, um Code mit NetzCAP Java auszuführen, um beliebige Dateien zu löschen. Und so ist es eben, dass die Leute dann der erste Bug publiziert wird. Und die NetzCAP Leute haben sich das angeguckt, haben gesagt, ja, aber kann man ja nicht benutzen, um damit Daten zu klauen. Und dann ist er eben nicht gefixt worden. Und dann kam der zweite Bug, und das war auch noch nicht so schlimm. Und jetzt mit dem dritten ist dann plötzlich das gesamte System zusammengebrochen. Und daraus müssen die Programmierer eben lernen. Am Ende, wenn man das nicht tut, ist eben schlecht. Und deswegen, man muss an der Stelle mal lobend hervorheben, dass Netscape die Kryptografiesachen nicht selber entwickelt hat, sondern da haben sie eben Leute eingestellt, die wussten, was sie taten. Und deswegen ist das auch relativ qualitativ hochwertiger Code, was man bisher sagen kann. Da gab es zwar auch schon Probleme, aber das sind echt Detailprobleme gewesen. Ganz am Anfang gab es mal ein Problem mit dem Zufallzeigengenerator, was ziemlich ein Anfängerproblem war. Aber insgesamt, es ist nicht so, dass die Firmen wirklich alle nur dumm und blöd sind und Anfängerfehler machen. Es gibt durchaus auch Software, die sich sehen lassen kann. Solche Firmen muss man eben auch unterstützen. Opera hat sich bislang noch keiner richtig angesehen. Da muss man sagen, den Webpause, da ist noch nichts publiziert worden. Das heißt nicht, dass der sicher ist oder dass der besonders toll ist. Bisher kann man nur so einfach draufgucken, kann man sagen, der ist schnell und klein, aber ob der jetzt sicher ist, weiß man nicht. Da muss sich irgendwann mal jemand hinsetzen, dem das am Herzen liegt, am besten die Firma selber, und alle möglichen Sachen ausprobieren. Wenn die gut sind, dann ist gut. Aber eine Sache kann man schon mal ganz klar von vornherein sagen, wenn es zwei Alternativen gibt, und zu der einen ist der Quellcode da, dann nehmen die, wo der Quellcode da ist, denn das können sich mehr Programmierer angesehen haben und Fehler gesucht haben. Das wäre doch eher ein Netscape. Im Moment ist ja für die Netscape-Version, die man bei den downloaden kann, der Quellcode auch nicht drauf. Aber für Mozilla gibt es den Quellcode des Netscape 5, und das nähert sich rapide der Stabilität und Benutzbarkeit insofern. Na klar. Wenn sich jemand hinsetzt. Na, da gibt es eine kleine Anekdote. Netscape hat das Standardprotokoll benutzt, was Programmierer benutzen, um Projekte zu sharen, nämlich CVS. Und sie mussten ihren CVS-Server upgraden auf eine, was sind das, 4-Prozessor-Maschine mit mehreren, also dreistelliger Megabyte-Bereich RAM, weil einfach Zehntausende von Leuten da auf den Code gestürzt sind. Also da tut sich was, das sind nicht nur 3-4 Leute, die ein bisschen rumbasteln.
Man muss sich natürlich bei dem ganzen Wirrwarr um die Browser uns auch mal vor Augen führen, was da eigentlich passiert ist in den letzten Jahren, also seit es dieses WWW überhaupt gibt, wo es vorher einfach, weiß ich nicht, alle anderen, alle übrigen Dienste gab, und dann kommt ein neuer Dienst dazu und plötzlich versuchen Leute, da Page Layout zu machen und weiß ich nicht, also auf einen Browser-Hersteller und auf das WWW-Konsortium und so, da kommen ja ganz unterschiedliche Berufsgruppen drauf zu, da kommen Designer, da kommen Fontografen, da kommen Leute, die dir den Inhalt interessiert, da kommen Programmierer, Sicherheitslücken, diese, der ganze Kram kommt auf die Leute darauf zu und wahrscheinlich muss deswegen so schnell entwickelt werden, wahrscheinlich braucht man deswegen dann auch schnell Leute.
Ja Herr Schad, das muss jetzt passieren, alle wollen da jetzt rein, das ist ganz klar.
Die haben alle viel zu wenig Geduld.
Aber das ist auch genau der Punkt, was natürlich super nervend ist, bei den Leuten, denen eigentlich jetzt durch Medien vorgegaukelt wird, das Internet ist das neue Fernsehen irgendwie, da passiert viel mehr als im Fernsehen, also schneller und toller und so weiter, weil es wird ja von vielen einfach als Konsummedium genutzt und nicht als das, was es mal war, nämlich als Austauschmedium.
Wir sind da auch nicht anders, wir sind ja nicht auch zum Konsumieren, wir konsumieren andere Sachen.
Das ist ja auch okay, wenn das ein Teil davon ist. Also ist ja auch kein Problem. Manche Sachen sind ja auch durchaus sehenswert und lustig oder können einfach klasse aussehen, das ist auch völlig okay. Oder man kann sich mal ein Video angucken, auch hübsch in der Größe. Aber trotzdem hast du natürlich auf einmal, dass dieses Medium für was benutzt wird, wofür es nie gedacht war. Und alles rennt eigentlich hinterher. Und ich glaube, dass so viele Leute jetzt da reinstürmen und sagen, jetzt bin ich aber enttäuscht, jetzt bin ich aber irgendwie, doch das, was mir versprochen wurde, von T-Online. Und deswegen wird halt schnell gemacht und damit schlecht.
Das ist doch immer mit Werbung oder nicht?
Man kann sich durchaus auch Zeit lassen mit der Empfehlung, jetzt Internet. Weil es ist ganz klar, dass sich in den nächsten zwei, drei Jahren das noch so rapide voranentwickelt, dass es durchaus gar nicht notwendig ist, sich da jetzt drauf zu stürzen. Also im Moment ist ja Hersteller Willfuchs und wenn man selber Geld dafür ausgibt, dann ist man es ja nach einem Jahr schon wieder los.
Übrigens, das ist keine neue Sache, dass Protokolle plötzlich für Sachen benutzt werden, für die sie nicht gedacht werden. Also das erste Mail-System, was es gegeben hat, als E-Mail erfunden wurde, hat noch FDP benutzt, um die Dateien auszutauschen, die Mail-Dateien. Und dann hat man sich irgendwann überlegt, dass jemand, der per FDP einen Mail abliefern kann, auch andere Leute Mail abliefern und lesen kann. Also das ist schon immer so gewesen, dass die Leute das genommen haben, was schnell funktioniert und so aussieht, als wenn es halbwegs tragbar ist und fertig.
Ok, gleich gibt es einen Franz-Korz-Info. Und dann haben wir noch etwa eine halbe Stunde Chaosradio hier bei Fritz Computersendung, der Computer-Blumuen, der den letzten Mittwoch ermordet.
Wenn Fritz im Raumanger mündet, dann 100, 1.
0 Uhr 33.
Gerichtstermin, US-Präsident Clinton wird am 17. August im Weißen Haus zur Lewinsky-Affäre vernommen. Seine Aussage wird auf Video aufgezeichnet. Es geht darum, ob Clinton eine sexuelle Beziehung mit der Ex-Praktikanten des Weißen Hauses hatte, ob er unter Eid-Log und ob er Lewinsky zum Eid anstiftete. Eskalation, die französische Polizei hat ihre Doping-Ermittlungen im Rahmen der Tour de France im Abend noch einmal ausgeweitet. Hotelunterkünfte von insgesamt sechs Mannschaften wurden durchsucht. Der Sportdirektor des französischen Casino-Teams wurde festgenommen. Der Fortgang der Tour wird immer ungewisser. Rettungsarbeiten, eine dramatische Hilfsaktion für die verschütteten Bergleute im österreichischen Lassing ist vorerst gescheitert. Ein deutsches Team stieg in das Bergwerk ein, musste aber in einer Tiefe von 100 Metern aus Sicherheitsgründen abbrechen. Die zehn noch verschütteten Männer werden in rund 130 Metern vermutet. Scharfmacherei. Israel setzt in der Jerusalem-Frage weiter auf Konfrontation mit den Palästinenser. Jerusalems Bürgermeister Olmert verteidigte Plänen, mehrere jüdische Siedlungen in die Stadt einzugemeinden. Über die Jerusalem-Pläne Israels beraten seit dem Abend die Außenminister aus 16 islamischen Staaten im marokkanischen Casablanca. Verdacht Die Steuerfahnung hat Tennisstar Boris Becker im Visier. Beckers Verteidigter bestätigte, dass Ermittler privat und Geschäftsräume des dreimaligen Wimbledon-Sieggewinners durchsuchten. Es gehe darum, ob Becker von 1990 bis 1993 seinen Wohnsitz tatsächlich in Monaco gehabt habe. Wetter In der Nacht Schauer 16 bis 14 Grad, tagsgelegentlich Regen bis 25 Grad. Verkehr Es liegen keine Informationen vor. Fritz wünscht gute Fahrt.
Ein Fritz-Kurz-Info mit Rina Gawoski. Rammstein.
Live in Berlin. Am 22.
August ist ausverkauft. Deshalb gibt's ein Zusatzkonzert.
August in der Freilicht Lüne Wohlheide.
Auch diesmal präsentiert von Just What You Need.
So, wir reden immer noch über das Internet hacken, bzw. wir sind so ein bisschen zum Thema Sicherheit im Netz gekommen. Dadurch natürlich, aber ist ja auch logisch, Attacken brauchen, gegen Attacken kann man sich nur mal mit Sicherheitssystem schützen und wir gucken mal, ob es noch Fragen gibt zu diesem Thema, denn die Leitungen sind immer noch geschaltet. Unsere Telefonnummer hier in Potsdam ist 0331, das ist die Potsdamer Vorfall und dann 70 97 110.
Hi, also erstmal muss ich ja noch mal jetzt für Erinnerung der Amiga User sagen.
Ja, ihr lacht, ihr lacht.
Ich finde, nein, ich kann es abkürzen. Der Amiga ist ein ganz toller Computer eigentlich, aber es ist wirklich, glaubt mir.
Ich kann mir das vorstellen, dass das Amiga nervt, wenn die da bei sich nicht irgendwelchen Töne voll haben.
Das ist wirklich erstaunlich, es sind auch immer nur die Amiga User.
Der Rechner ist geil.
Der Rechner ist gut, er hat ein verdammt gutes Betriebssystem. Das darf man echt nicht unterschätzen.
Amiga ist eh schon immer ein Klinik-Ableger gewesen. Also schon mal wahnsinnige Vorteile.
Nein, Amiga ist nicht schlecht. Die User sind auch dort normalerweise deutlich weiter als User von einem gewissen anderen System.
Aber nicht die, die in dem Chat rumhängen, wo Johnny auch rumhängt.
Das Problem ist, dass Amiga halt nicht nur ein geiler Computer ist, sondern weil er so ein geiler Computer ist, ist er eben auch zu einer Spielekonsole geworden. Da gibt es halt eine Gruppe von Amiga-Fans, die sind halt in der Super Nintendo-Ecke. Also die sind von der Spielekonsole-Welt her und nicht von dieser Programmierer-Welt her. Und da sieht es halt ganz anders aus.
Ich glaube heutzutage spielt keiner mehr auf dem Amiga. Weil wer heute noch in Amiga rumzustehen hat, das würde er glaube ich für alles andere mitmachen, außer spielen, weil das kann man mittlerweile auf einem anderen System, IPM-kompatibel und zum Beispiel hundertmal besser, oder?
Naja, würde ich nicht sagen.
Ich denke schon.
Also Computer gehört nicht gespielt.
Ich spiele auch noch C460-Spiele.
Ich meine, kennt ihr jemanden, der einen Amiga-Besitzer hinter den Unich hat, um zu spielen, oder?
Ja, aber wir haben hier Ecker-Teamer.
Also Leute, die auf ihrem Amiga Linux oder Freebies installieren, das finde ich schon mal sehr gut und die sollen durch alle anrufen.
Du machst das?
Ja.
Du fährst Unix auf dein Amiga?
Ja, ich habe Linux auf meinem Amiga zu laufen.
Und machst du auch Internet?
Ich mache auch Internet, ja. Aber Internet weniger auf der Linux-Seite, weil das war mir zu umständlich zu installieren. Ich habe auch gerade damit angefangen, weil ich froh war, dass ich das Thema zu laufen bekomme.
Das ist der erste Schritt. Das ist allen immer von alleine lernen zu können.
Eben. Ich finde es auch ganz okay, dass die Microsoft-Probleme, die Leute eigentlich nicht wissen, weil Microsoft sich nicht hüten, diese Sachen zu veröffentlichen.
Die veröffentlichen es schon, aber sie schreiben es halt irgendwo hin. Und dann war es keine D-WiL dazu.
Sie halten das als Text-Ansichtsproblem.
Microsoft hat die Informationspolitik auch gerade geändert. Sie sind dabei, E-Mails rauszuschicken mit ihren Sicherheitsproblemen. Sie sind also schon mal lernfähig, muss man sagen.
Na ja, aber nicht ohne Druck von...
Na ja, natürlich nicht. Und ich denke mal, da kommt jetzt auch Druck vom Militär, die sich auf Fragen von irgendwelchen Kongressabgeordneten gefallen lassen müssen, warum sie dann NT benutzt haben. Da wird jetzt auch einiges auf Microsoft zukommen, würde ich mal schätzen. Insofern, die sind jetzt auch unter Druck, keine Frage.
Eine andere Frage, das hat vielleicht auch was mit Hacking zu tun. TGP, in der neuen Version, ab der 5er Version glaube ich jetzt, da hat mir jemand erzählt, da ist auch ein Algorithmus drin, mit dem man mit einem Generalschlüssel alle Mails zurückdekodieren kann, ab der 5er Version.
Ja, das ist ein Firmenschlüssel, das ist nicht ein weltweiter Generalschlüssel. Also es gibt sowas für Firmen und es gibt aber auch eine TGP Version 5, wo das raus machbar ist und das ist aber jetzt eigentlich nicht Thema unserer Sendung. Also ich schlage vor, dass du mal Alta Vista befragst nach der PGP-Fact. Was sieht das dann?
Ist aber kein großes Problem. Ist nur in bestimmten Firmen ein Problem.
Okay, gut, dann grüße ich noch alle Leute bei Comtev, vor allem die, die nicht im Urlaub sind.
Und danach Mega-User. Außer die beiden Idioten, die vorhin... Man muss die richtige Mischung finden aus dem Netz sein und dann im richtigen Moment stinkern.
Du siehst immer wieder so kleine Lobbies von Aquamensystemen, die haben immer noch die größte Tatsache.
Ja, das ist natürlich auch kompletter Quatsch, über bestimmte Benutzer von Computersystemen herzuziehen. Aber hier schon mal sitzen und sonst nichts zu sagen haben. Hallo Christoph.
Ja, ich wollte eigentlich was fragen. Und zwar geht es um den, also Datei übertragen, geht es per FTP oder halt auch per DCC, also DCC...
CHEMI-RC.
CHEMI-RC, genau. Und zwar, wenn ich da jetzt bei einem bestimmten Provider bin, kann der oder, also technisch ist das wahrscheinlich nicht das Problem, diesen Dateiinhalt einfach mitzulesen oder abzuspeichern?
Ja, kann er bei beiden Protokolen.
Und macht er das auch?
Nö, wahrscheinlich nicht.
Wenn er es von iNews innen machen wollte, dann bräuchte er unglaublich viel Plattenplatz.
Kannst du also weiter deine Fotos tauschen?
Aber er kann es, er kann es und das wird auch getan, unter Umständen auf bestimmte Inhalte prüfen, während er es überträgt. Zum Beispiel bei E-Mail ist das halt sehr beliebt, das wird im großen Stil gemacht von den Governments.
Naja, es ging halt jetzt auch so um MP3-Dateien und so.
Halt dich für unwahrscheinlich, weil du überlegst, was da so getrailed wird im Internet, wenn jemand das alles mitschneiden wollen würde, der wird arm an Platten platt.
Aber sowas könnte sich schnell ändern, oder? Also wenn es weitergeht mit der gesetzlichen Entwicklung und Provider plötzlich verantwortlich gemacht werden für Webseiteninhalte, dann kommt als nächster Schritt wahrscheinlich für, dass sie verantwortlich gemacht werden für Programme, die übertragen werden und wenn dann eine Raubkuppi dabei ist oder ein Song im MP3, dann...
Also das hängt halt an diesem kleinen Begriff der Zumutbarkeit, der halt im Gesetz drin steht. So wenn halt dem Provider das technisch zumutbar ist, dieses und jenes zu tun, dann müssen sie es halt tun. Und wenn halt irgendwie Platten so billig werden, dass es ihnen zumutbar ist, ihre kompletten Inhalte wegzuspeichern, naja.
Also im Moment ist es so, dass keine komplett flächendeckende Überwachung stattzufinden scheint. Zumindest ist es nicht so, dass diese, wenn sie durchgeführt wird, dann irgendwie jetzt Auswirkungen auf dich hätte. Du brauchst keine Angst haben, dass du deswegen, weil du solche Sachen trägst, jetzt da erstmal rangenommen wirst. Auf der anderen Seite ist es so, dass wenn sie auf dich irgendwie aufmerksam werden, dass es natürlich dann möglich ist, die Sachen mitzuschneiden und auch als Beweismittel demnächst zulässig sein wird.
Aber das viel größere Problem ist, dass der Provider, wenn er möchte, natürlich dann die E-Mails lesen kann, weil die nämlich bei ihm auf dem Server liegen. Da würde ich deutlich mehr Hass vor haben.
Dazu muss man auch sagen, es gibt Provider, die ihre E-Mails auf großen Computern ablagern, wo dann sogar Zugänge zu diesen großen Computern geschaltet werden. Da muss man sehr kritisch überprüfen, bei wem man seine Mail dann eigentlich abspeichert, wenn man davon ausgeht, dass sie nicht mitgelesen wird. Nein, bei Internet-Providern, die Unix-Systeme haben, auf dem Mailsaber auch Logins zuzulassen.
Aber man muss vor allem sagen, selten ist das nicht.
Wenn die Brandenburger rauben, kommt es schon vor.
Das ist bei Internet-Providern natürlich nicht anders als sonst woauf. Wenn der Provider schlecht ist, dann kann er natürlich beliebig viel Lohnseel machen. Aber man muss mal sagen, Service ist wie Hotmail oder so, die E-Mails für jeden, der kommt, speichert. Im Grunde muss man sich fragen, wie finanzieren die sich und wer würde für Wärmung da Geld ausgeben. Und es ist nicht viel wahrscheinlicher, dass die davon leben, dass sie die E-Mails auswerten und dann irgendwie Leute weiterverkaufen.
Da gab es gerade diesen hübschen Hotmail-Exploit. Da muss man auf irgendeiner Webpage dieses und jenes CGI-Screen mit ein paar anderen Daten versorgen und dann kann man die E-Mails von einem gerade eingeloggten Hotmail-Loser auch lesen.
Welches ist denn schlicht verwandt? Ja, gut, sowas kommt vor, aber ich glaube nicht, dass es Absicht ist, dass es wieder mal ein Fall vorn hat, der Programmierer versagt.
Genau, oder nicht nachgedacht. Das ist meistens eine Ignoranz gegenüber dem Problem.
Tja, Christoph.
Also wie üblich nur mit Leuten zusammenarbeiten, mit denen man traut. Alles klar.
Das ist ja im Netz ganz einfach.
Ja eben.
Schöne Angst. Verdammt, vor ein paar Minuten fing mir da noch eine wichtige Frage an. Jetzt habe ich sie vergessen. Ach so, genau, jetzt weiß ich sie wieder. Also die Frage kam ja gerade nicht von ungefähr, wenn ich über IRC zum Beispiel Daten austausche oder über FTP oder so. Gehen wir doch einfach mal davon aus, dass es irgendwo Leute gibt, die zum Beispiel einen Song im Impact 3 tauschen. Einen Song, den sie natürlich eigentlich nicht tauschen dürfen, weil der Urheber rechtlich geschützt ist und so weiter. Jetzt kann dieser Falltransfer kann theoretisch gelockt werden. Was wird da gelockt? Wird die Datei selber gelockt oder nur der Name?
Beides möglich. Also möglich ist beides. Aber man muss mal sagen, der Durchsatz, den ein Provider leisten kann. Nehmen wir jetzt mal einen, der hier in der Nähe liegt, das ist Nafo. Ich weiß nicht, wie viel Internet die im Moment haben, aber es sind über 10 Megabit. Genau, deutlich über 10 Megabit. Nehmen wir mal an, es wären nur 10 Megabit. Und wenn man sich jetzt überlegt, wer würde das alles mitloggen wollen? Und sagen wir mal, die Leitungen sind nur halb ausgelastet. Also selbst dann sind das derartige Datenmengen, so viele Platten kann man gar nicht kaufen, dass man auch nur eine Woche davon mitloggen könnte und irgendwie den Platz auch noch hat.
Da muss ich aber ganz, ganz vehement widersprechen, weil es geht ja nicht unbedingt darum, dass jetzt alles auf riesige Platten zu laden und auf Jahre online zu haben. Aber die Möglichkeit, die Sachen mitzuschneiden, ist rein technisch inzwischen weit fortgeschritten. Also es gibt Platten, die wenig kosten und viel speichern können, gerade im Bezug auf irgendwelche komprenierten MP3-Geschichten. Also es ist nicht so, dass es technisch nicht möglich wäre, die Sachen mitzuschneiden.
Also vor allen Dingen stellt man sich natürlich vor... Ich habe deswegen gefragt, weil man könnte sich dann natürlich schnell auch rausziehen, wenn man sagt, das File heißt so. Ich habe das so genannt. Das heißt Roller-Dust, erstes Album. Aber es ist was ganz anderes, ein kleines Jungsprogramm oder so. Aber was du sagst gerade mit den Platten, es ist ja auch nicht so, dass das lange gespeichert werden muss. Also zum Beispiel bei Fritz werden ja alle Sendungen auch mitgeschnitten, auf Videoband, auf halber Geschwindigkeit und so. Dann hast du eine relativ höhere Qualität. Und das hat rechtliche Ursachen. Also ich weiß nicht genau wie lange das ist, aber ein paar Tage oder eine Woche oder so müssen die dann archiviert werden und dann werden sie wieder neu überspielt. Das heißt es geht eigentlich nur darum, wenn ich jetzt sage, mein Nachbar ist doof und der zeigt mich an, dann kann der Sender nachweisen, nein ich hab gesagt, mein Nachbar glaubt ich sei doof. Das kann natürlich einem Internet Provider genauso passieren irgendwann. Und dann heißt das, der hebt diese Arteien vielleicht für eine Woche auf zehn Tage und dieser Plattenplatz wird irgendwann bezahlbar sein.
Der ist auch jetzt schon bezahlbar. Man muss aber folgendes sagen, Provider in Deutschland haben das Problem, das ist nicht so einfaches Geld zu verdienen als Provider. Einfach weil, wenn man kalkuliert, dass es zwei, drei User geben wird, die einfach eine Leitung von morgens bis abends belegen, weil es für sie billiger ist, als zu sagen, ich bin eine Firma und möchte eine Standleitung haben. Irgendwie sowas kommt vor. Wenn man einfach mal durchkalkuliert, was eine Standleitung, so eine 2-Megabit-Leitung, die ein Provider mindestens haben muss heute, was die allein an Telekom-Kosten kostet und was da noch dazukommt an Kosten an den überliegenden Provider. Dann rechnet man noch die Telefonkosten, die einfach Grundgewöhn für die Modermanschlüsse sind, die er als Teil in hat. Und dann hat er dann noch einen Server, den er e-Mail macht. Da kommen einfach schon so viele Kosten zusammen, dass das sich wahrscheinlich niemand leistet, es sei denn, er hat wirklich Grunderwähle.
In dem Zusammenhang sollte man vielleicht auch in irgendeiner Sendung, ich weiß nicht zu welchem Thema, es passt mal, auf diese ganzen Billigangebote eingehen. Da muss man irgendwie auch mal drüber reden. Also abgesehen von Providern auch irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, hier für 2, 50 Mark, dein eigener Server und so, da muss man vielleicht mal ein bisschen Licht ins Dunkel bringen. Also ich kenne es von der anderen Seite, dass Leute einfach kommen, warum soll ich denn dafür 50 Mark bezahlen? Der hat mir das für 5 Mark angeboten und es ist teilweise extrem schwierig, Leuten zu erklären, was da passiert.
Nein, ist ja auch gar kein Problem. Die Leute gehen dann dahin und sind nach einer Woche sehr böse und nach zwei Wochen richtig böse und nach drei Wochen sind sie noch viel böse und nach vier Wochen gehen sie dann eben. Also es ist ja nicht so, dass man es nicht lernen kann. Die sind ja dann auch unzufrieden mit dem Service. Und normalerweise ist es so, wenn ein Provider richtig billig ist, dann finanziert er das eben dadurch, dass er weniger Einweilleitungen hat. Und weniger ausgehende Leitungen kann man natürlich auch haben. Der Effekt ist bei wenig Einweilleitungen, dass ständig besetzt ist und bei wenig ausgehender Leitungen, dass man zwar mit ESDN reinkommt, der T-Online-Effekt, dass man zwar wunderbar zu T-Online selber Verbindungen hat und von den 8K-Karbeit pro Sekunde möglicher Leistungen werden dann vielleicht zwei oder anderthalb benutzt, weil einfach T-Online schlecht angemunden ist. Und das ist eben so, wenn der Provider spart, das merkt man als User. Und dann muss man eben gucken, ob man nicht zum anderen Provider geht.
Gibt es schon einen Ausblick auf die nächste Sendung?
Ja, aber da muss ich jetzt gleich noch mal nachgucken.
Also vielleicht muss es gar nicht so. Mein Gott, das ist noch ein Monat, in dem Monat kann viel passieren.
Wir haben uns das irgendwie auch schon alles zusammengelegt, aber das ist noch nicht so vorbereitet. Also es steht zum Beispiel noch nicht im Web.
Guck du doch mal ein bisschen rum, und wir machen hier so einen ganz schnellen Durchlauf mit den Hörern. Also ich nehme jemanden kurz ran, der kann eine Frage stellen, ich versuche mir ganz knapp zu beantworten, und ich schmeiße ihn gleich wieder raus, weil hier sind die Leitungen noch voll. Mal gucken, ob das funktioniert. Hallo, wer ist denn da?
Oh, ich bin schon noch auf Sendung, sorry.
Folgendes, ich habe einen Apple Mac in Tausch, und bin in Sachen Internet noch relativ unbeschlagen. Zum Beispiel, eine so Grundphilosophie ist, Reduktion auf das Wesentliche, und bei dem Thema Browser, da kann ich jetzt diesen Navigator und diesen Explorer von Microsoft, aber ihr habt vorhin so etwas wie Opera genannt. Gibt es das auf dem Mac?
Noch nicht, aber weit.
Opera ist in Vorbereitung für den Macintosh, das dauert noch ein paar Wochen. Es ist angekündigt, dass er bald rauskommen soll, aber stay tuned, also das dauert noch ein bisschen.
Und was Ähnliches, was nicht so groß fett ist, und vielleicht noch weniger Komfort haben kann?
Nimm mal einfach eine alte Version.
Ja, es gibt Lynx auf dem Macintosh, Mac Lynx, der kann halt keine Bilder direkt anzeigen, sondern zeigt nur den Text an, aber der ist super schnell. Oder eine alte Netscape-Version, das ist auch ein bisschen schneller als die neuen Netscape-Versionen. Derzeit ist auch noch alle, also Internet Explorer ist auch schneller als Netscape auf dem Mac, allerdings ist er auch deutlich instabiler. Also derzeit sieht es eigentlich ein bisschen blöder aus. Was richtig cool ist, gibt es nicht. Ach man, Entforscht. Das Internet ist nicht toll auf dem Macintosh, also die Programme lassen sich in der Regel prima benutzen und laufen auch relativ stabil.
Ist ja gut, und der T-Pot ist auf dem Mac.
Netscape 405 stürzt bei mir am seltensten ab bisher. Noch seltener als 201.
So, jetzt kann ich dir auch sagen, was wir in den nächsten Monaten vorhaben.
Ja, das war übrigens dann so viel zum Thema Schnelldurchlauf ein oder?
So, nächste Sendung wird sich mit einem etwas kritischen Thema auseinandersetzen. Da wird es etwas politischer. Da haben wir nämlich Jugendschutz und Internet. Ein Thema, was derzeit extrem in den Medien ist, mehr als ein Lieb sein kann. Im Monat drauf werden wir dann nochmal richtig auf dieses Problem Privatsphäre und Kryptographie eingehen. Also dann nehmen wir das mal richtig ins Visier. Bisher ist es oft angeklungen, haben ja wieder große Reaktionen gehabt, aber da werden wir uns dann direkt darauf konzentrieren. Und die Sendung da drauf, die November, die Oktober Sendung, die wird besonders. Da will ich mal noch nicht so ganz so viel drüber sagen, aber das ist halt die Sendung, wo der Film 23 gerade rausgekommen ist.
Und das ist die 33.
Sendung? Und das ist die 33. Sendung. Und dann ist noch irgendwas im November. Und im Dezember ist dann wieder Chaos Communication Congress. Dann macht auch Chaos Radio mal wieder eine Pause.
Wo ist denn der? In Hamburg oder Berlin?
Da sag ich jetzt auch erstmal noch.
Das heißt, ihr versucht, ihn noch nach Hamburg zu kriegen?
Es ist noch nicht klar, wo er sein wird. Aber er ist wahrscheinlich in Hamburg. Hamburg ist ziemlich sicher. Aber der Ort wird vielleicht ein anderer sein. Weil wir ein kleines Platzproblem hatten letztes Mal.
Gut, das war es fürs Chaos Radio in dieser Juli-Ausgabe. Das war der Chaos Computer Club. Vielen Dank.
Bitte schön.
Mein Name ist Johnny. Und ich hoffe, ihr habt ein paar spannende Sachen erfahren. Ansonsten, nach wie vor der Tipp, wenn euch Sachen interessieren und weiter interessieren, dann die Suchmaschinen anschmeißen, mal ein paar Worte probieren, sich mal vor allen Dingen mit Newsgroups auseinandersetzen, ist immer wieder mein Lieblingstipp. Weil es, da gibt es noch, Boris Becker hat es mal gesagt, es gibt noch mehr wie Tennis und es gibt noch mehr wie WWW im Internet zu finden. Also Newsgroups nach wie vor der heiße Tipp für gerade computerspezifische Themen, wo man sich dann ganz gezielt mit Leuten auseinandersetzen kann und wo auch eine Unmenge wirklich netter, freundlicher Menschen sind, wo ich immer wieder überrascht bin, dass die meine blöden Fragen beantworten. So, das war das Wort zum Sonntag.
Guten Morgen!
Das ist dein Tschüss. Ups, falsche Platte. Na, macht ja nichts, kann passieren.